okay folks today's episode 124 is with
rola tomasi the rational male we're
going to talk about what it is to be
alpha what it is to be beta
i think the question of the day to be
honest with you everybody wants to know
what is a soy boy it's it's like
especially for our top for a podcast
it's a critical yeah yes or no we're
talking about this
we're going to talk about the black pill
we're going to talk about a lot of pills
that you know apparently people are
taking the blue the red the black
apparently there's a white pill
uh uh i wanted to get your uh uh
thoughts on that i know we got some
current events that we're gonna get into
so having said that you know the book
the rational mail okay that i think it's
nine different things that you talk
about in there there's a lot of things
that you talk about
yeah but so how how did you go how is a
guy that's been married nearly for 30
years write a book about how to be an
alpha male and rational male well first
off um i think you need to uh define
what is an alpha male that is a beta
male when i talk about alpha or beta i'm
talking about in term like abstract
terms
so it's not like i'm the the comparison
isn't where like silverback gorillas or
you know wolves on the arctic tundra or
something like that it's it's a
placeholder term it's an abstraction so
to say there are guys who are of a
higher class or of a higher value than
there are of guys who are you know just
sort of around the middle guys average
average men right now
so when when you say something like
alpha or beta people want to turn it
into sort of like scientific terms like
etymological terms right they want to
say well you guys are just comparing
yourselves to you know gorillas or
something like that it has nothing to do
with it whatsoever so
defining what that is the book is not
necessarily meant to say okay here's how
you be an alpha male kind of thing what
my work has done over the course of the
last 20 years now
has been to explore intersectional
dynamics as a part of that yes
male nature is a part of that female
nature is a part of that and how do
those two natures play on each other
and how do they do that from a mac or a
micro level to a macro level so all you
know all the way down to you know uh
what it what is it that makes uh a guy
attractive what is it that makes a woman
attractive and then from that point from
that point forward it's how do they come
together how do they have sex how do
they form families and from those
families how do they form tribes from
those tribes how they form nations how
to in and on and on and on but you have
to go all the way back and sort of
distill it down to the intersexual
dynamics between men and women and
that's what i attempted to do in the
first book and then i've got uh well
three other books since then that are
just supplements to the to the first
book rollo before you became this
rational male like you guys were you
know kind of doing a community college
competition over here who had a better
community college upbringing in past
days
but was
is standard available this standard
question 101 okay
so
so first thing is i've been married for
25 years as of july of last year
so thank you and um
so people always ask me that how did you
come into this you know this situation
did somebody break your heart was there
some point like well how did you get red
pill kind of thing
and it was a more like a slow process
not necessarily some sort of you know
break breakup or anything any like
there's no catalyst to you know oh well
i'm gonna this is gonna make this my
life's mission it wasn't about that it
was just curiosity for a very long time
uh i grew up as i said in southern
california um i was part of like say the
the late 80s early 90s you know metal
scene that was going on in uh in
hollywood at the time
thanks yeah um
and so from there you know i kind of got
my act together after after a while um i
mean i've been through bad word breakups
just like anybody else has but that was
not necessarily the catalyst for me to
say okay this is what i'm gonna do
uh i have had a very i say unique set of
circumstances over the course of my life
so uh going from uh from that situation
from southern california just sort of
being a a kid really in my 20s
wanting to have a good time wanting to
party wanted to get you know it
certainly was about the money back then
it was more about getting laid so um
that was my my impetus at that point and
then of course you mature you get a
little bit older uh you know i met my
wife in a lake tahoe area
and um and so from that point you know
you have kids and you sort of you know
reassess where it is what you want to do
and set goals for yourself and you know
sort of mature um i'm generation x so
maybe that's that had something to do
with it as well
we have a lot of listeners they're what
18 to 40 give or take for the most part
some are single some are getting out of
college some are in relationships some
are married
what's the outcome of this conversation
just so we're all on the same page is it
to expose what's really going on out
there you're going to drop some
knowledge hey this is what you guys got
to do to improve your life
where are we going just so we can set
the tone okay
so the the if there is a a purpose or a
point to my writing it is to educate
okay it is to educate guys to give them
the tools so that they can make informed
decisions when it comes to their
personal life first and foremost and
second of all from that point where do
you go from there how do you change your
life i am not in the business of making
men better men i'm in the business of
giving men the tools so that they can
make themselves better men i'm in i'm in
the business of not prescriptions but
descriptions and so what happens is then
people will take those guys will take
those and better their lives save their
save their own lives and in many
instances as well
um and then it's not just about getting
laid a lot of people want to want to
mischaracterize what it is that i do and
say well it's just those pickup artists
it's just those
we're talking about pickup artists in
about pickup artists that were in in the
scene back in 2002. so we're talking
about 20 years
the game by the way was published in
2005.
all the events in there took place
between like say 20 or 2002 and 2000 so
fair to say the game has changed very
much so and that's the i think we we
want to run back to that when we want to
mischaracterize when we want to uh we
want to just you know dismiss and
ridicule all of that but it has matured
to the point where it used to be just
about you know pua and like how do i get
laid guys come together on forums they
start comparing notes it's sort of this
aggregate of information between guys
all over the world
well it was the first time in is the
first time in history where we had the
internet where guys could get together
and sort of compare notes all over the
world and from that point it was it
snowballed from there into
how do i live a better life how do i how
do i find uh if that's what they wanted
to do how do i find a girlfriend it's
not all about notch count a lot of guys
use the red pill just so they can get a
girlfriend in the first place or go from
you know being a quote unquote perma
virgin to you know getting getting a
girlfriend or you know getting into a
situation where they're in a
relationship at that point so it's it's
all about what you do with it rather
than okay well this is the point this is
the importance of it it doesn't have any
particular point to it it's a praxology
not an ideology got it so question for
you this this book rational mail
who who agreed with you who disagreed
with you who said
i that's evolving agree with what he has
to say dude the guy is full of he
has no clue what he's talking about
you write books you're going to have
people from both sides absolutely who
liked it we still do still do it's
mostly guys that hate it yes
interesting yeah uh okay i'm gonna i'll
tell you a really quick funny story here
when i was writing the second book which
is the preventative medicine it's a
timeline and everything that you know
what to expect from women at certain uh
phases of maturity um i i started that
book with an introduction because i had
a guy relate this story to me that he
was reading the first book rational mail
and he was uh he was there you know
checking it out on his couch or
something his girlfriend's wife whoever
came in and said you know the rational
male who's there's no rational male is
laughing at it she's like give me that
i'm gonna i'll decide you know what this
is all about the girl read it yeah the
girl read it she grabbed it from him and
it took her like maybe uh three or four
days to to read it she just like ate it
up she comes back to the guy at the end
of the week and she tosses it back to me
she says everything in that book is
correct and you shouldn't know any of it
and that was uh
yeah yeah because it gives away the game
it gives away the it gives away the uh
the mechanics the underpinnings of like
what's going on um you know sort of the
the dance between men and women and
that's that's when i get hate from from
guys it's usually because they're they
don't know how to apply this
or it conflicts with a very deeply held
ideology like their ego invested in this
what we call you know the blue pill
ideas where it's like this is what
you've been taught from from uh from a
societal perspective from a western
societal perspective this is how men are
this is how women are and this is what
you can expect from them and then
they'll get into that point where they
have um
or they have that bad breakup or they
have that bad divorce or they're going
through some kind of trauma and it's
only at that point where they go they
start questioning about you know
was what i taught you know for real or
not and so
this you know the the work that i do
kind of steps in and fills in those
blanks so
i'm sure that a lot of our conversations
can be based around the red pill and
being red pilled and blue pill
apparently it's a black pill i don't
know if there's a white belt but would
you break down what each of these pills
are and exactly i wish we could get past
the stupid pill thing okay
i really wish i really wish we could
okay so first and foremost the red pill
um in the way that i talk about it um it
i i only refer to it in terms of
intersectional dynamics okay um
ever since we started using that
terminology and i can go back to my old
forum posts from 2004 and show you the
the posts where we were we were talking
about the matrix and unplugging it
because that was the closest analogy
workable analogy
and
so over the years since i you know peg
it at about 2004 over the years um
it has morphed into like mra's mgtows
the black pill which is a more like
despondent nihilistic do with doomers
the doom pill kind of thing
um like a hopelessness and then there's
the guys who are simply red pillow where
they take this this information and they
use it to their to their own benefit as
far as a blue pill is concerned we tend
to refer to that as like uh your sort of
upbringing your your understanding is
society would like you to believe how
things you know work
um white pill is just something that
sort of it's more like the purple pill
at this point where it's uh you got the
the red pill in the blue pill and guys
become red pill and they they read the
book and they become aware of
intersexual dynamics but it conflicts
with their ideologies or their religions
or their philosophies and so what
they'll do is they'll pick and pull
parts out of out of uh out of my book or
whoever's you know
podcast they happen to be you know
watching
and then
use that and and jump on top of that and
then just reject whatever parts that
don't fit in with their ideologies
so really the white pill is just sort of
this it's a it's meant to be sort of
this positivity movement but again it
just picks and pulls from from red pill
awareness let's just say um again i
really wish we could get past the red
pill because i remember back in like
2015 2016 when trump was running for
office everybody suddenly was red pilled
about
politics or red pilled about whatever
whatever your pet ideology happened to
be and that was you know the blue pill
was false and the red pill was true then
therefore you you know the red pill
became a verb you're saying how do i
become
well phrases you've been using for a
decade for instance uh candace owens
when she was on twitter she used to call
herself red pill black that was her
handle on on twitter before she became
candace right and so it was this
appropriation of what seemed like a good
you know tag or a hashtag or a buzzword
that worked at that time now i would i
would say that a lot of people say oh i
got red pill about politics i got
repealed about this but it's not as
as
i guess appropriating from what had come
before it as it is right now yeah so but
let's go back by the way the purple
thing you know
first thing i thought about when he said
purple pill is being at the mushroom
mountain a couple times once or twice
but nothing comes close to the
yellow and uh purple pills right you
know who's this uh d12 is this eminem
that's where i went all the way
anyways but going back to it so look the
one part i like how you explained um
the fact that women go through different
phases so do men so you know for myself
i said okay i can see some of that stuff
making sense to some people and i
totally can see that meaning
how men change once they get married how
women change once they get married
and then you know some women are like
well my man is no longer interested in
me like he used to be and some men
are like well you know my girls no
longer my woman is no longer interested
in me like she used to be right so if
you don't mind going through the phases
we go through so
when i'm 18 years old i'm in the army
you know
what do you have on you know there's
only one thing on your mind right that's
reading a lot of business books i mean
analysis trigonometry that was a main
outcome of my life at that time i'm
lifting weights i'm fired up i got a lot
of testosterone running a bunch of miles
every day and somehow somewhere you got
to release it so 18 to whatever age
then you get to a point you look at the
market and you say okay
that girl chose that guy over me what
the hell are we talking about here
that guy is a schmuck but he's making
money and he's going to get over me this
doesn't make any sense and i don't even
like his attitude he's like so you know
okay let me go try to compete in a
different way then you go maybe a little
bit more into career you get focused and
if you do it early on you have the
ability to win but what phases do men go
through and if you can kind of go all
the way through to maybe 50. sure and
what phases do women go through i'd be
really curious okay well it's it's
actually easier for me to start with
women because
the second book is exactly about that i
i pegged it as at a timeline now there
is a very famous graph that i uh
published way back in like 2013 or 2014.
it's a it's two bell curves it's when
women are at their peak of their sexual
market value versus when men are at the
peak of their sexual market value and in
in many different ways men and women do
not mature at the same rate okay even
when it comes to like puberty when it
comes to you know like girls mature a
lot faster than boys do and they get to
a point where they're they're uh is that
with you what you're talking yeah that's
the one i'm talking about right there so
they can see it keep going we're
listening so i and i you know i'll tell
you it's funny when i was writing the
essay where i put that out there i was
like this is like in kind of instinctive
to me and then a lot of people ran me up
the flagpole for for putting this one
out there and then over the course of
the last say like almost 10 years now
there's been so many data sets and so
many so much research that backs this up
and i almost get chills thinking how
accurate it was when i was writing it
but what the where i peg women as far as
their their peak sexual market value is
right around 22 or 23 years old that's
when men find women the most attractive
across the board 23 24 23 24 right right
around there so 15 all the way up to 95
that's the age at which men find women
the most attractive for for women
finding men attractive it staggers so
statistically speaking women find men
three to seven years
older than they are as more attractive
now there's a difference between arousal
and attraction and a lot of people
sort of mistake this if you ask a woman
what do you find attractive in a man
she's going to tell you all these
long-term security you know traits that
a guy has to have you say what do you
find around what gets you hot about a
guy uh let's see he's got to have you
know v taper he's got to have you know
you know 26 inch guns he's got to have
six-pack abs he's got to have you know a
chiseled jawline that's that's a
difference so
um when men get to be about 36 years old
is when i peg them at being their at
their sexual market value peak because
that is assuming the man makes the most
of his potential
is
you know developing himself becoming
something lives up to his burden of
performance let's just say at 36 to 37
somewhere in there that's when he starts
hitting his stride that's the point at
which he has the potential to have the
most of what makes him the most
attractive to women overall so if you
stay on your game you're working out and
you're on top of your business and you
are on you know you have ambition you
have confidence a lot of that takes a
lot longer for men to develop than it
does for women to get to their point of
seek of sexual you know marketability
and so uh one of the things we always
talk about in sort of the manosphere or
the red pill communities is that men
must become and women just are so when
women get to the point where it's like
they're at 23 that's when men want them
the most so that's that's number one
must become a woman just women just are
huh so because so does that mean just to
stay on that and i want you to continue
so does that mean
uh uh uh
for a man to increase the market value
wait till at 37 36 37 i don't think
that's what you're saying no no no but
i'm saying that that's going to be the
point at which you will have the
potential to have the most of what will
make you the most attractive that's
based on what that's based on well based
on on
physicality also the fact that women
want a man who's older i think on an
instinctive level women want a guy who
has a more maturity has more of a
capability or proven capability to be
the winner that they want to get with
well those guys don't tend to be part of
their own peer group they tend to be the
guys who who are more mature because
they have had longer to i don't know
become partner at the you know law firm
or get become a surgeon or whatever it
is that they find as sort of you know
status wise as high value but also um to
stay on top of their game build
themselves up and have a better judge of
character there's a lot of things like
if you look at the prerequisites that
women have on the most common dating
sites it is this laundry list of he's
got to be funny he's got to be hot he's
got to love his mom he's got to like
puppies he's got to want kids he's got
to what he got you know have ambition
he's got to be confident and just on and
on and on and on for men it's she's got
to be hot she's got to be available
that's pretty much that's pretty much it
and so when you go and you look at the
this uh it's almost like filling out a
job application when you're going on say
like you know tinder when i tinder so
much but like you know online dating
which is the number one way that men and
women find each other today and start
you know start dating so
when you have that as sort of the
prerequisite well women understand that
it takes longer for men to develop into
what's going to make them the most
attractive and to mature into that and
as a result that has to coincide with
what they're going through so when when
a woman is between say 18 and 28 years
old that's her peak window to find the
guy that has the most of what she's
going to need in the future so if you
look at it this way a woman between 18
and 28 years old she's got about 10-year
window there to secure what she's going
to need as long-term security for the
rest of her life so that's a that's a
lot of especially today that's a lot of
stress on on women right now to find
that guy
so would it not stand to reason that
they're going to look for a guy who is
already a winner a turnkey relationship
where she can go and say oh you make a
lot of money you've done a lot with
yourself um yeah i'm ready to you know
ride or die with you or she's going to
have to look for a guy who has the
potential to become that guy when he's
36 37 years old at his peak so women
will go through the phase of what i call
that you know i call it the party years
i was just saying that it was it's the
it's the point at which women are sort
of like expl they have the most sexual
selectivity during those years other
people will call it the whole phase
not my words their words um and then
they'll get to a point where it's uh 29
to about 31 years old which is what i
call the epiphany phase and that's when
women go i'm done with the jerks i don't
want to i don't want to have that
anymore i want to do things right i want
to get right with god i want to have a
right relationship and unfortunately in
our our western society right now that's
often too late for women at 30 31
well i'm not saying necessarily it's the
wall like they don't look good anymore
they do the wall when we talk about the
wall the wall doesn't begin here it
begins up here it's acknowledging that
they are not as sexually competitive in
the sexual marketplace at 33 as they
were when they were 23. do you think
that applies to today
what all the uh
what do you call it
you know plastic surgery would all be oh
yeah there's ways to forestall that
right sure right yeah but you're saying
that 33 that's 30 29 or 31 that's the
age well the the for most women their 33
year old self could not compete on the
same level in the sexual marketplace as
her 23 year old self
well also kids play a major factor in
this afternoon with kids and decisions
not even so much what it does on your
body like
if i like i'm single uh
41 now
40 uh
2 43
[Laughter]
and uh
at least according to a certain online
dating profiles um for three years in a
row 41. i'm 40 again guys
congratulations
by the way yeah we we didn't do even do
a happy birthday here we take it out to
dinner
adam just had a birthday a couple of
days ago turned 40 years old for the
first time in the last you know couple
of years whatever
and uh so
i appreciate adam's birthday
on your on your dating profiles by one
year maybe
um
the
rolo this is about
keep going i'm actually curious because
you said 30 you know you're now at 30 29
to 31 years old you went to 36 well male
you know peak market value is 36 to 37
years old female market value based on
your rationale is 20 to 23 to 20 24.
continue what happens after that well
not necessarily my rationale this is
this is backed up by research and data
there's a great book called data
collision and it was written by the guy
who was the founder i believe of okcupid
and um today in the internet you know
age we now have data that we never had
in the history of humanity right now
especially i don't know if you guys
i i brought this up when i was on you
are here with elijah shaffer um if you
go and you look at the pornhub
blog site not the pornhub site but all i
did was watch the blogs yeah just read
the book
uh they just put they just produced the
the stats for 2021 um of basically what
were the search you know terms what were
the most misspelled search terms yeah
and and by state like who who looks for
what and we have such accurate data um
that tells you like the peak market
values
really we have never had i can actually
see that well i can actually see data so
what were some of the biggest findings
so anyways and i don't mean so much on
on on pornhub thing but like in a in a
data collision that's where i get that
uh that's where i might the basis of the
idea that men find only find that age of
woman the most attractive because it's
from their data sets um for women it's
uh if the woman is like say 25 she's
looking for a guy that guy's more
attractive is about 27 maybe 28 and then
it staggers up at the older that woman
gets the older the men get so it's sort
of this you know staggering for men it's
only 22 23 20 across the board from all
the way from like 15 year old guys in in
high school all the way up to 95 year
old guys in you know assisted living so
um that's
everything i'm getting out here is not
opinion pieces all of this is backed up
by hard hard data that anybody can find
by the way you we have google right now
we can i quote data sets from
evolutionary psychologists
anthropologists
neuro you know psychologists
sociologists there's all kinds of data
sets that we've never had before so it's
not just me sort of pulling this out of
my ass it is based on research that has
you know been going on really in some
cases since like the 70s but all the way
up to where we are right now so when we
get to sort of what i call the epiphany
phase 29 to 31 years old that's when
women decide that that's you know i'm
gonna have to check out of the sexual
marketplace i gotta find a guy to go
forward from here and that's when women
will express the most frustration with
men they will say where are the nice
guys where are the guys that that how
come these guys don't have their
together how come they uh they haven't
gone to college how come i can't find
the guy that i want to go forward into
life with right now and that's a whole
nother topic to get into when we talk
about the crisis of masculinity but when
they get to that point at 29 to 30 you
know three years old somewhere around
there
that is when the that's when that sort
of angst comes in if you look at the
another data set if you look at the the
average age of first marriage it occurs
right around 29.8 i think or almost
about 30 for men and about 28 to 29
years old for women today and that is in
the united states it's even older in the
uk there's only a one year difference
that is exactly where i pegged it on
that on that chart exactly now you said
you're gen x so you're give or take 50.
i'm 53 53 looking good bro and how much
how much of an age difference between
you and your wife
uh let's just say there's a three-year
difference
so let's just say there's a three-year
difference yeah so when she hears you
use this terminology 23 25 is she like
rollo step into my office mother sucker
we have a problem here how do you
grapple with that's being married
i have kids i have a dog okay so how do
you grapple with that saying what you
say versus living what you live well i
have an obligation to uh objective truth
and i of course picked that up from dr
godsod thank you god
um but
it is
incumbent upon me to tell things like it
is and sometimes that can come off as
sounding like it's angry or it's it's a
cynical or it's pessimistic some may
call it rational some would call it
rational um really that's a sort of a
conflict i i have written about quite a
bit about the uh the war between
rationality and reason versus
emotionalism right now uh my wife is on
board let's just say with about 98
of what i've ever written i mean it just
sort of depends on mood for the last 20
questions exactly what yeah
exactly and that's the first thing
anybody says well i think it's more
about like what is what is most uh
expedient when it comes to women's
mating strategy versus men's mating
strategy which one should be the the
predominant one that like decides how
we're going to live
in a you know a post-21st century world
right now
which mating strategy defines our social
policy which mating strategy but whether
it's men or it's women we used to call
it patriarchy right now patriarchy by
the way died right around 1965 it died
the year after hormonal birth control
was introduced
very very slowly but it died right at
that point and
when i talk about um when i get into
like emotionalism versus rationalism i
get this question all the time it's like
well what does your wife disagree with
you about like that's the one little
like yeah but there's 98 that she does
agree with
so um
usually it's just it's it's more or less
it's logistics not not necessarily like
a particular point in the book per se um
but do you say things to your wife like
you better stay hot for me baby you're
getting a little bit older not in those
not in those words
but in in your in your innuendos
my wife looks very my wife
both of us have a commitment to staying
in shape right okay um and uh
you know it's it's innuendoes yeah
there's there's a certain game that goes
along with that it's not like uh it's
not like it's something that's like
conscious at this point i say this on my
own uh podcast it's like i am the game
right now because i've been doing this
so long i've been studying this for so
long that it becomes second nature it's
it's internalized
so am i going to it's not an ultimatum
if that's what you're asking it's not
right you better do this because or it's
not like she goes through my book and
she goes well it looks like you're using
this point right here on me like it
doesn't work like it's playing the game
yeah play with her and play with her so
you're you're the market of dating and
alpha male you know there's a bunch of
them right now right on youtube that are
doing this and there's some younger guys
that are doing it there's some married
guys that are doing it there's some
girls that are doing it you know women
are doing a bunch of bunch of folks are
testing this out because i think there's
a need for it people want to know how to
increase their market value right so
now if somebody listens to this they're
like what if i pass that age i'm
kind of discouraged what do i do right
i'm not at that prime age or i'm not at
this age so what what is the non-natural
because i know when you use the word
natural what is the what can the
non-natural do to increase their market
value both men and women
um as far as sexual market values
like like you say you're available
you're single okay
and you're in the marketplace right now
and you're like listen maybe you're at
not not at the best place career-wise
you're kind of trying to get it together
maybe you're trying to make a comeback
and maybe you're somebody you're a woman
who is you know 34 years old and you're
single
and your last relationship didn't work
out maybe you're a single mother right
now and you left your husband or vice
versa right you're by yourself what can
that person do to increase their market
value to be attractive to the opposition
um very easy for men um there's
there's three core aspects and really
four if you think about it there's uh
make muscles make money and learn game
and in terms of game i mean like social
skills that a lot of guys by the way are
very lacking these days and then as the
fourth part of that is is a whole frame
like so once you have built that world
you know with make money make muscles
learn game then you have frame as a part
of that and again this is a
psychological sociological term like
what's the frame right now
and it doesn't necessarily have to do
with just you know interpersonal
relationships it can be your boss it can
be your your your mom or your dad and
your family there's like frame is like
whoever's frame psychological frame
you're entering into or they're into
entering into yours
so one when we're looking at uh guys
sort of coming back from from being like
okay i'm deficient in these areas most
men when they
when they find what works for them they
gross out in one of those areas so i i
don't make a lot of money i'm kind of
poor but man i can go bench 400 you know
400 pounds
i'm in the 300 club right i can whatever
it is i can i can maximize my looks and
everything at the cost of my deficiency
in say money or even in game we see a
lot of this in black pill communities
right now where they think it's nothing
but looks it's you know to the point
where they're doing jaws or size so they
can get a better you know jawline or
doing you know cosmetic surgery as a
result of this
really kind of obsessive uh
misunderstanding that it's all about
it's only about looks okay
so what you would think that these guys
would be like you know uh jim bros or
they would be like personal trainers or
something but that's one area that is if
you're deficient in one of those areas
you tend to gross out another so what i
would suggest is look at which areas you
tend to be really strong at and then
look at where you you tend to be weak at
most guys if they're weak in money they
they tend to gross out on looks if
they're if they're fat and they don't
look very good or they're not naturally
good looking they tend to gross out in
money and say well it's all about the
money and all i have to do is just pay
for everything and girls will want to
come to me and then it's like there's
the game aspect of it well i don't have
either of those but i'm very charming
and so therefore i can you know i know
people's psychology and you tend to
gross out in that area as well my
suggestion to guys is if you want to
have a if you really want to build
yourself up look where you're weak in
those three core three things because
the fourth is to have frame as a result
of all of those three things so if you
are not in good shape which what is it
75 percent of the united states
population is like overweight and like
40 percent is like morbidly obese that's
usually the best place to start get your
fat ass in the gym that will help you
out with with your uh just not
necessarily the just the look side of
things but it'll help you feel better
because you're you know releasing stress
and there's there's a chemical
biochemical aspect that goes along with
that if you're deficient in money people
will say well how do i get on my game
with money uh crypto how do i do how do
i become an entrepreneur how do i learn
a trade how do i like i'm better at
these things find out what your core
strengths are um primarily if i'm when
i'm telling guys like they've asked me
this question
first and foremost i say what is
sedating you
is it pornography is it booze is it uh
prescription drugs is it your uh and
your addiction to world of warcraft
whatever it is whatever that is sort of
your video games it's a life that is
it's better to live in your escape than
it is in your shitty real life that's
that i think that's the first and
foremost is find out what's sedating you
because you can't address any of those
core three until you decide until you
figure out what's keeping you in bed all
day long and you're not you don't want
it do you think this metaverse concept
is gonna help us
it's fun we're just talking about this
um yeah i think it's going to i think
it's going to hurt because it's going to
be more like i think a more immersive
experience right if you're not happy
with your life just go check into the
verse good luck remember when world of
warcraft and those online role-playing
games came out and everybody was you
know neglecting their children because
they were too busy you know trying to
level up um if that's human nature
imagine what it's going to be like when
we get into the metaverse and we're
already talking about like you know
women are
filing suit against meta for like being
you know sexually assaulted yeah in in
the metaverse right now and you're
already seeing like real world problems
sort of being transferred over into
into the the metaverse like we're
already it's a natural shift over but
yeah i think that that will be an escape
that will be a sedation to keep you
locked in place to keep you in neutral
um for women um my my biggest concern
with women and it's funny you brought up
you know what if you're a divorced mom
of five or whatever um
and you want to get back into the game
well first and foremost you have to
remember what it is that men are looking
for uh and at what what particular age
uh i'm 53 years old if i were to find
myself single i'm not going to be
looking for a woman who is saying like
25 years old because i've already gone
through that phase of life i'm mature
enough and i can think critically enough
to go you know what it might be fun you
know to to have a fling with that person
but you're not going to build a life
with that person going a lot of people
in palm beach would disagree with you
yeah well yeah i know yeah that's right
i got offended it's going to be all
right
so for as far as women are concerned i
think women need to
look uh see the force for the trees
right now i don't think a lot of women
uh
look ahead long term uh i work with
these guys fresh and fit which are in uh
in miami here um and you're probably
familiar with them they have one of the
number one podcasts and certainly in
southern florida if not you know dating
podcasts over the world um
they bring in women regularly and
they'll say well they're all you know
ratchet hoes from the clubs or whatever
like that no disagreement yeah but um
but and so you can but when you listen
to these girls they all have the same
stories i'm i'm i'm looking for a guy
who is you know the guy's going to take
me on yacht parties i'm looking for this
i'm looking for a guy who's got money
i'm looking for
it seems like they're looking at in you
know sort of towards the future but what
they're not understanding is that at the
pa at their point of life say like
i said 18 to 28 years old they don't
realize that their sexual selectivity is
like the party's going to be over at
some point because they're going to be
replaced by the next cycle of 18 to 28
year olds that come in so you know the
joke is this is you know they called the
store forever 21 not forever 41 right
because you're looking for women are
always looking back at that peak that
those peak years because that's when
they had their their the top of their
agency they're at the top of their power
the power curve that i was saying before
and they they constantly look back to
that and as as women go forward i think
there's almost a blue pill for women as
well which is we'd sell women on this
idea of what i call fempowerment and
we've been doing this really since 1970
since the the sexual revolution
we want to put women into the workplace
we want to uh we want to have special
dispensation for them in colleges we
want to get them into stem fields we
want to give them access to you know
pell grants and all kinds of uh ways to
sort of you know build them up put them
into the workforce put them into
politics put them into the economy as
much as possible the problem is that
what happens is women end up becoming
the men they want to marry they end up
becoming the quote-unquote alpha female
or the boss babe or whatever it is now
um and they can't understand why they
can't find a guy who is their
quote-unquote equal who doesn't want to
have anything to do with them
catastrophic because anybody who is
better than they are status wise is not
looking for
a quote unquote alpha female they're
looking for the girl who's 23 years old
who's feminine and wants to have you
know go forward and have kids and has
you know say well she's submissive
whatever
i
counsel women today who tell me i can't
find a guy i can't find a guy who is uh
my equal but he's got a you know they're
not going to college men are enrolling
at like 40 versus 60 for women right now
i'm sure you've probably seen those
stats um and
so there's this socio-economic disparity
between men and women right now that's
causing this divide but it's also this
expectation and we expect women to sort
of dumb themselves down so that they can
get with a guy who
that you know up to that point they've
been raised on these ideals that they
should never settle that they should
never settle for anything less than the
best and
you know statistically speaking the best
is making 58 more than that woman does
to forestall divorce when a woman gets a
a rise in pay or she gets a you know a
promotion at work that is what
precipitates divorce in couples where
they were making the same or or she was
making less and now she's making more
those are simple biological evolutionary
reality
you know here's what i would want to
know because he's right
not not what he just said is right he's
right with the data side everything's
out there with data right i would love
to tyler see if you can search is what
we're talking they would leave the
camera on us i'm seeing if tyler can
find this i would want to know i
probably have it well if you have the
data tell us we'd pull it up to show it
i would want to know what is the average
rate of a woman
that divorces a man her income to her
versus
man to a woman i don't know if that
makes sense or not so
woman files a divorce to the man man
files a divorce to the woman what's the
income okay i'll be just curious you
know because i'm different
i have a friend of mine
that uh he's been married to his wife
uh rolo for 15 years okay
she's a lawyer she makes a couple
hundred grand a year he's a stay-home
dad
and she's crazy about him she would
never leave him and he has no desire
to go be a career guy he drops off the
kids in the morning makes them breakfast
packs their lunch
and he's he's not a uh he's not a softy
like if you looked at him you wouldn't
be like oh this guy's a little pansy
he's a he's he's not and then
they're happily married he's not career
driven he wants to be the
soccer dad is who he is he's exactly
what a soccer mom is except he's a
soccer dad she's not a cook he is and
they're happily married
and that's working out for them right
but i also have friends who will call me
and they'll say
i said what's going on you seem like
you're upset what's pissing you off
something's bothering you well yeah
listen man i mean i don't know i'm like
finally let's just say we're having a
conversation they'll open up they'll say
you know
would it bother if your wife made more
money than you
he asked me this question opened the
question you know we're like three four
guys were talking shooting the
would it bother if your wife made more
money then i said why do you ask that's
what happened with me and my wife just
got a raise right now and we got some
fights at the house i said why does that
bother you well i feel like i have to be
the one making more money so
psychologically he couldn't accept it so
does that concept vary based on
men and women because sometimes i see
women who are stronger personalities
marry a guy who is not necessarily an
alpha he's a little bit more of a chill
it's okay nothing pisses him off and
that works out because
i think the one thing about these
philosophies is
from my experience i don't think there's
anything that's an absolute truth right
i think there's generalities and there's
majority and then you got the exception
you know to the rule what would you say
to that okay well first and foremost the
idea that um that men and women uh are
equal is a misnomer because i think what
we do is when we talk like
people throw me under the bus for this
one but i don't i don't believe in
equality and i don't mean that in terms
of like oh we shouldn't all like strive
to be equal i just think that our
understanding what is
equal is sort of out
it's it's subjective and it's obscure
it's it's you know relative to whatever
uh the challenges are that uh men and
women face
in you know in life so if i wanted to
get pregnant i'm a man that i can't do
that because i'm a man so that seems
very unfair and unequal between the two
of us it just depends
yeah well yeah apparently so apple
thinks you can can you pull up the new
emoji by apple apple thinks you can't i
don't know exactly i haven't figured out
yet but yeah but it's a painful
experience but but biologically speaking
reality objectively speaking there are
there are always going to be
differences between men and women and
how we define what's equality and what's
justice and what's fair and what's not
fair is really just dependent on what
the challenge is so if i'm flying out
here on the on the plane and some lady
says can you please put my bag in the
overhead because because you're taller
than i am and you're stronger than i am
and you can put it up in the overhead
well that seems very nah go we're all
equal go ahead you you do it right i'm
not going to defend you i don't we're
all equal today right no i'm going to go
of course pick it up and put it in there
for her but that's what i'm talking
about what's the challenge and the
challenge in this case is just simply
taking your your luggage and putting it
in the overhead bin right so
when we when we talk about equality we
need to say what's what's the challenge
under what parameters what's the context
that we're talking about here so when
you're talking about your friends who
are uh you know the man is sort of like
the mr mom right he's the stay-at-home
dad he wants to be the soccer soccer dad
or whatever else um odds are that uh
what does she do for a living a lawyer a
lawyer okay and what is what did he do
before he became this or how do they
meet i don't think he's ever had a full
time okay is he a good looking dude
there's probably something that offsets
you there's probably something that
offsets what do you mean he was he was
very handsome right now he's got a
massive belly and just uh he's got the
dad bod and he's just some women find
dad about talking yeah but that's what
i'm saying to you but here's the thing
though what are you going to change
about that's working they're good with
it and they've been together 15 years
are they doing something wrong so you
know that's not that's the another
exception that's what i'm saying that is
the exception i agree with that so
all i'm trying to say is the one part
that adam i will see
is
like you know in the company we have a
lot of couples in the sales company so
i'll see sometimes the wife is a bigger
alpha than the husband yes and he's okay
with that
like he doesn't have the insecurity of
saying i want to be the alpha that the
fact that he doesn't have that
insecurity makes him an alpha i don't
know if that makes sense the fact that
he's not trying to impose is like dude
i'm so happy and they're killing it okay
and he got some guys that are the alpha
and the wife that support him some that
run together but
that's that's very much an exception for
you because especially in blue-collar
couples i mean you're talking about
somebody who makes a lot of money in a
completely so different socio-economic
class you're looking at a larger whole
women
file for divorce 70 of the time and
that's the lowest estimate i have
actually i have higher estimates as well
um and three out of four times the one
so
what precipitates that is usually that
woman has gone their blue collar workers
have the woman has gone up in in status
as a result of a promotion or whatever
and now the guy is making less money or
in the case of your friend here he was
never making that much money in the
first place now your lawyer friend goes
to you know the practice and she's
having to defer to men who are her
authorities who are her superiors guys
who are very powerful high status guys
that she has to interact with every day
is she going to come home from that
situation and go back to her soccer dad
husband and say yeah i will i'm going to
submit to my husband i'm going to you
know are we going to suddenly come back
into that traditional conventional
gender role after working 40 hours a
week with guys who are much higher
status than the guy that she has to come
home to every day who's changing diapers
and and you know cooking mac and cheese
so
that is the power dynamic that goes
along there because women are looking
for a man that they can look up to
women cannot look up to a man who is her
equal she's looking for a guy who makes
more money than she does she's looking
for a guy who is more on top of his game
as a quote unquote dominant alpha male
she's looking for the guy who is is in
status wise above herself if there is
some sort of anomaly that's going on
there where she's like oh i'm good with
it because he's a good-looking guy
i would have to say well what's her
situation as well so it's not just about
like okay was he a good-looking dude as
you said he was what is her situation
again money muscles game and frame so
where does he fit in on those core four
right there um you could probably say
she's more attractive than him you would
say so you would say so okay so in that
case and he's not a porn star so he's
not packing yeah yeah i know where you
want to go you know what i'm saying no
yeah well i mean
you have to take that into consideration
right you have to say okay well she she
wants to get with this guy i mean i know
dozens and dozens of women who are
actually at least two of them are my
clients right now who complain that they
can't find the guy who is that higher
status guy and so they have to sort of
dumb themselves down i'm not saying you
should i'm saying they feel like they
have to dumb themselves down just so
they can get with a guy because more men
are simply not
average women don't want to get with
average men they want the guy who they
can look up to and admire and
from a
you know a an average american uh
perspective like blue-collar workers
when that woman is elevated to a
different position that's what
precipitates divorce
so so
you're familiar with gloria allred you
know what gloria already said okay yes
so you know sometimes you know we are
sold a philosophy
by somebody who has had dramatic life
experiences that we haven't had right
but they impose
their philosophies on to you and you
kind of sit there and say i'm gonna buy
that but you shouldn't buy that because
it may not work for your life it's extra
but because the other person's such a
better salesperson it's so much emotion
into it you buy into it right you gotta
be very careful which philosophies of
people you buy so i remember when i
interviewed her gloria we're in our
office i walk in
and you know she
she's a perfect like she's the for
people that know who glory already is
how do you define who she is michael
jordan of sexual harassment lawsuits
right can we say that yeah an attractive
older woman accomplished by the way i
had the most incredible time sitting
down with her when the interview was
done because things got heated when the
interview was down i said can i hug you
she says you know what patrick all you
have to do is ask that's the key i'm
like okay so she gave me the biggest hug
we laughed it out but i pushed her she
pushed me i said look gloria you talk
about feminism and women's rights and
all this stuff how many people you got
working here a lot why is it that the
front desk clerk was a woman but all
your partners pictures on well they're
all men well well well are you how about
you patrick are you not a bigot it was
like such an interesting dynamic but
then i said i want to find out about
this later lady when i looked at her
documentary looked at study stuff on her
when she was in cancun do you know the
story about what happened to her can't
go in a mexican show when she was
younger in her early mid 20s very
attractive girl
she goes to a doctor she meets a doctor
dr says let's go back to my practice i
want to show you my office in the office
she she he rapes her okay
and she keeps it to herself for a while
but she creates this
level of anger towards a man right
so later on she gets married uh to this
man then they get a divorce i think
after she gets a divorce you know he
ends up committing suicide the guy kills
himself her first husband and his second
husband she gets married they get a
divorce she keeps the last name but sues
the hell out of him and he saw what
happened to her daughter her daughter is
now kind of similar doing what she's
doing i don't know if you're following
the she's following her footsteps
similar personality strong personality
and she's out there saying independent
women independent women independent
woman independent woman and women are
like she's right she's right she's right
and it may work for some but some
actually do want to have a family do
want to have you know do want to have a
husband do want to stay you know build
something together with them how do you
differentiate between
you know somebody who is selling a bag
of goods that maybe worked for her
because she had a painful experience how
do you process that how do you get
somebody who is listening to this saying
well she's right
versus saying i don't know if that
philosophy is going to work for me
longer it's it's very
difficult to
make a rational argument with people who
are like seated and steeped in
emotionalism and anger is definitely an
emotion and resentment and and you know
regret um revulsion there's all kinds of
different emotions that go along with
that so i can be the most rational guy
in the world and say here's the
statistics here's here's the dynamics
here's just the dots that i'm connecting
yeah i'm not going to change that
person's mind if we're if if she's
having an emotional
argument and i'm having a rational
argument because we're talking past each
other um my
most people when they have a a conflict
of interest or they have like oh you you
believe in a philosophy and i'm like no
i don't believe in a philosophy i
believe in empirical data here it is uh
the only way they can win that uh that
rational argument is by converting it
into an emotional argument and that's
you know in a nutshell kind of what
happens when you're trying to relate um
red pill awareness when you're trying to
relate the kind of material that i do to
people who are very
ego invested into like their
personalities are dependent on that
belief set so unless they get to a point
of crisis unless they get to a point of
of really kind of desperation or they
have you know through some miracle they
have some sort of insight about things
you're really probably not going to
change their minds about it
the best you can do is to present you
know pick your battles uh ask uh lead
the witness right ask uh pertinent
questions at the time when those when
those
topics arise um but as far as like when
we're talking about like this
cultural narrative of the power in a
strong independent woman right now it's
practically a brand we've been talking
about the strong independent woman since
1970 since gloria steinem okay
and
why is that a broken philosophy well
it's a broken philosophy for several
people some people some people swear by
it independent of what what are women
independent of
men they're independent of men's
provisioning so when we go about
remember i told you how everything goes
back to the micro the micro level is
this for women women's mating strategy
is hypergamy okay and i mean that on two
fronts it's dual it's not just one like
a lot of people mistake hypergamy as oh
well women marry up it's not just about
that women also are looking for
short-term sexual genetic benefits they
want the hot guy in the foam cannon
party in cancun on spring break you know
they want the hot fireman that arouses
them and gets their blood boiling and
then they want the guy who's also like i
said attraction who is the guy who's a
good long-term security prospect so it's
cads versus dads that's the that's kind
of like the dynamic that women have to
choose they have to find the best fit
between those two things in today's
society really since 1970 we have
developed a a social order that has sold
women you don't need to worry about
long-term security we've got
we've got no fault divorce we've got uh
child support laws we've got uh the
duluth model of feminism we've got more
women in the workplace and just go on
down the line of all the benefits that
have that women have accrued since the
time of the sexual revolution all of
those point to one thing which is
long-term security for women so when
we're talking about like abortion on
demand that's a fail-safe for bad
reproductive choices that is the
function of abortion is to say you know
what well i i he's not i don't he's not
a good prospect for the future but this
guy is and so therefore we have that
option just having that option that is
exactly why women will fight tooth and
nail to keep abortion legal that's
number one you think that's the reason
absolutely that's the function of it so
p women will say well it's because of uh
you know bad to say what really what
else is it i mean is it is it uh
is it bad philosophy is it bad religion
is it bad whatever so let's practice
what is this what is the purpose where's
the label so what you're saying is what
you're saying is if if a girl
hooks up with an nfl player she'll keep
the baby but if she hooks up with a you
know neighbor because one night she was
alone and he came he was a schoolteacher
a regular guy she may abort that baby
but keep the nfl that's what you're
saying and that's exactly why you have
no seat at the table when we start
talking about abortion laws you don't
have a uterus and therefore you don't
get to you don't have a say
you know what nfl training on that by
the way just a side note nfl train that
every time you have sex with a condom uh
flush the flesh account it was an nba
nba that yeah i mean now it's everybody
have you seen what happened recently in
the news than tabloids with drake and
the hot sauce and the condom situation
you know where he got that from was tom
lycus from back in the night
because i did i did a segment on that
everyone's like tom like the time i go
there what's that tom lycus yes
my question is like drake why are you
putting cholula sauce in a freaking
condom just flush it down the toilet i
don't know if it was an environment
i believe it was 2001 the nba released a
press release to all their players who
are on road trips because they had such
a high incidence of women that they were
sleeping with while they were on road
games uh essentially uh they would use a
condom and the women would let's say
inseminate themselves with the leftovers
in the condom so that they could have a
kid with an nba player so that is a goal
of many of those it was so common that
they had to make a press release for
that and of course tom like is being the
extreme guy who has you know this is
well you should put tabasco sauce in
there so like when she does that but
continue you were saying continue you
were you you were going to a point there
once feminism and why it's not an
effective strategy abortion so and
that's just one one factor that goes
along and so what we have done is we've
established a social order where men are
unnecessary and women today will say
this we don't need men we're still i
don't need no man i don't need no man
but i want a man okay
what man do you want to get with what
man is that it's usually the guy who's
the quote-unquote stereotypical alpha
chad guy hot guy in the foam cannon
party she wants the alpha seed side of
hypergamy not the beta needs side
because at least there's this idea that
that side of security that side of her
mating strategy is going to be settled
and when they get to the point where
they're 33 34 35 years old and they're
asking me rolo where are all the good
guys how come i can't find a guy who is
you know makes more money than me or is
is ready to go forward they're also
irresponsible they're all threatened by
powerful strong powerful women and the
only answer i have for them is you have
created yourself into the man that you
wanted to marry
and so when when women hit me up and
they asked me about this and they say
okay well what can i do what can i do to
be uh to to find a long-term a long-term
guy and they're 34-35 years old and
these they get very very frustrated
they're like i'm i guess i'm going to
die alone you know i guess that they've
resigned themselves to to you know being
a spinster let's just old spinster
exactly and so what i say is well you
know what are the men uh that you're
looking for what are they looking for in
a woman well they're looking for
femininity they're looking for a woman
who's hot they're looking for sexual
availability they're looking for a woman
who can nurture who might be a good
mother in the future i mean there's all
of these sort of conventional
feminine qualities that they don't
embody anymore and so when they say well
what do i got to do i got to play dumb i
got to play the ditzy blonde i've been
told my whole life that i needed to be
in charge and powerful and everything
else and as as uh
as patrick was saying just a minute ago
is women
want to be or they believe that they
need to be in those positions of power
because they can't depend on a man men
are irresponsible men are untrustworthy
men like gloria all red for example
i i don't need no man or they have a
very uh
misandrous uh attitude towards guys as a
result of life experience or whatever
but it doesn't even have to be something
as dramatic as that it can be simply
like watching disney pixar movies that
do nothing but say you can do anything
you can be an astronaut and have babies
at the same time and you can you know be
in the military and fight wars and you
can go and be a computer whatever it is
you know the sky's the limit girl and
you have you know three four generations
of women who are raised on that they
believe that they have to be the one who
provides that security for themselves so
as a result you have careerist women who
are getting more degrees than men we
constantly we point at men when we talk
about this but let's look at the stats
here there are more women who are
enrolled in college there are more women
in doctor programs there are more women
who get master's degrees um i mean just
educationally speaking we can we can you
know parse that out women are making
more money than than men are these days
are increasingly more anyways um and
then women spend more money that that is
part of the family unit right now
percent of of uh american homes the
woman is the one who makes all of the
the big economic decisions for those
homes so it's not necessarily earning
capacity or this wage gap kind of thing
it's who is making the spending who's
doing the who's who holds the purse
strings and we can see that on the
family level and you can also see that
on the societal level as well so if you
go look at the who's in charge of the
imf right now
who's in charge of the the fed who's in
charge of the uh with the emf right yeah
well yeah you look at i think it was on
zero hedge had a really great story
about this is like the world's economies
are now controlled by women or these
those are the heads the figureheads of
those organizations some may say some
may say
a feminist may say to you
rolo you're just insecure you're afraid
we as women
are starting to take your jobs away and
we're making a market more competitive
why are you so insecure and afraid of us
okay what i would say is that's an
emotional argument and i'm making a
rational argument it's the same thing
it's a conversation killer who hurt you
that kills the conversation right there
if i go and i i make all of these very
cogent very rational valid arguments or
i show you the statistics and say these
are just the st these are the stats
these are the dots that i'm connecting
and if your response is who hurt you or
oh you must be very bitter what was her
name you know or mommy didn't love you
that's an emotional response so it's the
same thing it's like well you're just
you're just an insecure man because
you're bringing this up no i am giving
you objective reality and you have no
counter argument these women that you're
saying you're speaking to there that
approach you and have these
conversations that are doing well in
life successful are they're literally
saying what do i have to do dumb it down
you've used that play stupid you've used
that terminology a few times what does
that actually look like what is they're
not going to just start being a deal no
what does that actually look like
we're going to find out is what we're
going to what we're going to do
right now if you look at marriage rates
they're at the lowest they have ever
been since the in the united states
anyways than than when they started
recording this it's like i believe it's
up to
6.1 percent per thousand right now i
believe that it's 6.1 but it's at the
lowest rate it would have been six point
one percent
6.1 per 1000 i believe of the population
it is what does that mean statistically
speaking it's the marriage rate in the
united states is lower than yeah yeah
but what's six point one per one thing
that's um i i got it off of um uh
per 1 000 unmarried women
years older so can you pull this up
because i'm actually really curious on
what that means
uh yeah i i do know fewer people are
getting married one thing that's the
lowest rate absolutely i mean i got one
chart here that says marriage more than
a century of change
if you go back to 50s 90.2 percent
of folks were getting married today it's
31.1 percent
yes okay the u.s marriage rate the
number of women's marriages per 1 000
unmarried women
15 years and older is the lowest it's
been in over a century at 31.1 that is
roughly 31 marriages
per 1000 unmarried women
the marriage rate was the highest in
1920 at 92.3
since 1970 the marriage rate has
declined almost 60 percent why is that
happening i would say it's because we
have a different understanding of how
men and women should interact with each
other we have taken away anything that
men might provide to women because
they're strong and independent women
right that side of hypergamy where it's
the the three piece parental investment
protection and provisioning women can do
that themselves and uh when we have a
social order that makes men like homer
simpson or we turn them into incompetent
men or we say we can just simply look at
the stats like 40 of guys are going to
college right now um there's this new uh
i forget what the
the guy's name john berger i think was
he coined this phrase called the golden
penis syndrome right it's like these
guys who are on top of their game
they're the god they're the alpha the
quote-unquote alpha males that all women
want to get with well they
don't need a man to provide security for
themselves anymore and they don't trust
a man to provide that security in the
first place because their whole concept
of masculinity is ridiculous or it's
abusive those are really the two or
incompetent those are the three
choices that we have
you have you have you have two kids i
have one one daughter one daughter
twenty three okay boom this is perfect
so
your advice to one yeah exactly i mean
yeah no no this is
just before you have a 23
she's at the quote unquote prime of her
life right now people i'm sure you know
if she you're her dad and a hot mom
she's looking all right what are you
telling her you're saying hey listen
babe you've got a few years to
capitalize on this i want you go to
school i want you to be successful but
not too successful and here's what i
want you to do what what are you telling
your daughter well my daughter's already
a girly girl to begin with okay she's a
pageant girl by the way she knew uh
what's the black girl who just committed
suicide the
the pageant winner girl who
i forget uh chris uh i forget a name
chelsea christ i think is what her name
is
which is very tragic tragic this just
happened yeah it just happened yeah um
and so uh but she's she's very she's
very feminine she's naturally feminine
um she is she's got a good head on her
shoulder she's doing postgraduate work
um i won't tell you what
what college is on publicly but um she's
just finishing up her post grad um she
has a boyfriend who is very much alpha
guy a hockey player
and so older
yes
yes and she um she naturally i think
gravitates towards guys who are
i would say follow a certain template or
a certain model um and yes to to be
honest with you i've said the same thing
i said you know you are at the prime of
your life you're at the peak where
you're your selection your p you're what
does she tell you
is that well see that's the problem
i mean this is my daughter this is royal
tomasz's daughter okay so this is kind
of like i'm biased here or she's going
to be biased because she's getting this
from me but um of course like the
the problem that most women have with
what i have to say when they have a
problem with it is they tend to conflate
sexual market value with their personal
worth and that's i think remember you're
asking me what advice would you give to
women i would say look there's a
difference between your sexual market
value and your personal value so when
women say well look i've got a career i
have a my own business i have all this
stuff i did everything that i was told
to do by the books i'm a a powerful
alpha female and um
and i you know still can't find a man
but this is where i'm at how dare you
tell me that uh that i'm not hot or i'm
not attractive and the problem that i
have is that when you conflate sexual
market value with your personal worth
your personal worth becomes what you
think should be attractive or what men
should find attractive in you men are
not necessarily looking for a woman who
is a high-powered ceo or an attorney or
whatever they're looking for a girl
who's like good-looking feminine and
sexually available and they want to get
with that and anything beyond that point
once you've established that
relationship that's all gravy after that
point but they're not looking for a guy
they're not men generally heterosexual
men are not looking for another guy to
marry they're looking for a woman to
marry because that's the complimentary
nature between men and women you're not
you're not even talking about
homosexuality you're not you're talking
about
another woman
can talk about oh
no no but in this context you're talking
about they don't want to marry a
woman who is trying to be a man like
that's what you're exactly yeah they're
looking for the yin and the yang right i
mean they're like i've said this before
like people will throw rocks at me so
let me be clear right now from my
perspective men and women are innate
natural evolved compliments to one
another my strengths as a man complement
my wife's weaknesses as a woman and vice
versa we are better together than we are
apart and the problem is as you were
saying before is that we have this
separation why aren't people getting
married why aren't we forming these
monogamous you know families why you
talked to jordan peterson a little while
ago was a
socially enforced monogamy why is that a
thing in the past all of a sudden it's
because men or women literally have no
use for men except for a few top tier
guys that they're
being whether by force or by choice are
being forced or choice to uh to choose
that one guy and share that one guy so
when we talk about high-powered guys and
having you know why would that guy who
has at the peak of his sexual
selectivity maybe he's 37 years old 36
or seven years old he's on top of his
game he's he's hitting his stride he's
made his first millions he's got his own
business he's got he's the success story
of
manhood why is he going to want to get
with a woman who is like his equal who
or that he would perceive as his equal
and not get with a lot of hot girls like
dan bilzerian or something like that or
get with with a lot of women at one time
you have that sexual selectivity and
then choose from among them who he wants
to have children with and who are you
quoted jordan peterson was just here
friday um sitting your seat right there
and basically i've seen him say saying
women want to date
horizontally or vertically meaningly
like your same status or above where men
is just like
i'll take it from women take a three to
a ten i don't give a women have uh
women have attraction floors men do not
have attraction floors and what i mean
break that down yeah well let's just i
mean let's put it in nuts and bolts here
is if you've got a guy who is like a six
he'll date a woman who he would love to
get with a woman who's a nine but no
one's ugly after two a.m right so we
have a much we have
we have a much broader um
uh
much broader scope when it comes to you
know the women that we're willing to get
with either as mating opportunities or
as like say a relationship our stand
like men today are simply not even
allowed to have standards so when we
talk about like well what do you look
for in a woman most guys it's like well
you know she she was there and then it
just seemed like it was the right thing
to do for women if a woman is a six
she's looking for a guy who's a six or
above and if that guy is a six she's
looking for that guy she'd be the guy
who's the seven might be somebody that
she wants to get with it's uh it's
not necessarily a sort of mating but it
is looking for the neck the bigger and
the better deal and does that mean now
because people are gonna give me this um
does that mean that you know well if i
get with a woman she's always going to
be looking for the next big bigger
better thing no because hypergamy is not
a straight jacket and what i mean by
that is as women mature their ability to
you know discern what's my sexual
marketville uh sexual market value
versus his if that woman is say a seven
and he's a six at 28 years old when they
get married and now they get to be in
their 30s their mid-30s and suddenly
he's made partner in the law firm he's
made maximize his potential he goes up
in sexual market value while she goes
down a notch that's what i'm talking
about maybe that's what solidifies that
relationship and it makes it a healthy
relationship it's not necessarily like
well oh i'm doomed because women i why
would i bother getting with a woman
who's just going to go look for the next
best thing it's not just about that
there's a lot of variables that go along
you know we were doing a uh we were
doing a uh uh show that we're testing
and you know yesterday we were talking
to uh you were not in the room so
zack's on the blind date with this girl
okay and we're testing this show and
this therapist
from behind in the back what a
walkie-talkie is talking to each person
that they're dating right
so meaning the girl's got a headset
that she's speaking into
and you the guy on the blind date's got
a headset that she's speaking the same
person two walkie-talkies one is yours
one is hers right
and she says to him ask her this
question
are you okay with open relationships if
we date are you okay with open
relationships
and
she says
yeah i would be open to open
relationships
and then she said to follow up with the
question of why would you be open to
open relationships right obviously
there's a place that she's going to
you know there's a lot of talks about
open relationships right now
yeah what is this story with open
relationships i think that that is sort
of the the
adaptation that's going on right now
because a lot of like as you were just
looking at the traditional marriage like
where's one man one woman they get
together they have two kids in a you
know golden retriever in the front yard
right um that is a dying model that is
an old order model it's a 20th century
model today in the
21st century in the social media era
women are exposed to uh what is it the
paradox of choice right it's they all
you have to do is go on your cell phone
and go on tinder and like you got
there's far more guys on tinder than
there are women on tinder so this sort
of gives this idea that women are have a
higher
a higher threshold when it comes to like
well attention or when you know from
from other guys
um so there is the idea anyways this is
this is the in theory anyhow is that
poly is an adaptation for the um the
situation that's going on between like
what used to be just sort of the nuclear
family right now so when a woman for
instance when a woman when we're talking
about polly polly works differently for
both guys for for men and for women so
when we think of poly we think of one
guy who's like yeah man i got i got
three girls here you know this is great
you know they but guys want to have that
variety you know they want to have like
the three ways or whatever it is um the
common fantasy that so we think of
paulie in those terms but when we look
at it in a modern sense paulie really
kind of comes down to who's the most
attractive and who can leverage it the
most in today's society it's women that
can leverage it the most because they're
the ones that get the most attention
online in a social social media pers you
know perspective again going back to
those stats uh i had them here just a
second ago but it was uh if you look at
how couples met
over the from like 1950 all the way to
2020 and you look at like friends and
family school church whatever else it is
and you look at just like how low those
numbers are right now and there's one
huge spike right now and maybe you'll
pick he'll pick at that huge spike right
there that's online dating and that is
like not that's only in like the last
like 15 to 10 or 15 years right there
that is what i'm do you want to know why
polly's so popular that's why polly is
so let's look at that let's look because
of online dating
well because of choice because or even
just the the presumption of choice
and i'm sure that's even higher because
that's 2017.
yeah so through friends
33 to 20
bar restaurant
went from 19 to 27 percent so that one
higher i'm sure it's lower for kovit
because ain't nobody going to bars or in
covet right at work it went from 19 to
11 percent does that mean people are no
longer working
school college from 19 to 9
through family 15 to 70 percent wow so
they're no longer going to thanksgiving
you know
so so uh going back to what we're
talking about with uh
this whole thing about availability
right we looked at a stat a couple
months ago if you remember the stat
where
the percentage of folks who were getting
married online
versus through family it was seven times
higher do you remember that stat it was
do you remember that's that way we
talked about there's an article we
covered people that meet online are more
likely to get divorced and and people
who meet through friends or family are
the most likely to stay married yeah so
people who meet online are more likely
to get a divorce and people who meet
through friends and family
and i think friends and family was the
highest if i'm not mistaken right
friends and family and always work why
do you think that is why do you think a
divorce is higher for online than
friends and family okay well again it's
uh you're spoiled for choice that's
that's first and foremost um you have to
look at the people well that's the one
that's actually what i was looking at
right there the if you look at that
spike that really dramatic spike right
there that's and when when did that
start right around 2000 i can't see it
from here 1999 1999 all the way up to
where we're at right now i i all chat as
well i see a lot of i see a lot of yeah
but is that groundbreaking that's like
saying no no social media is where
people are are doing what they're
talking about the way they're saying is
tv was what he's saying is availability
actually our understanding our
expectations of marriage our
expectations of forming a relationship
are based on pre-2 000 standards i'm gen
x your gen x i believe
but even if you're millennial right now
you're still you still remember an age
in the 90s if you watched an episode of
friends that's old the old order way we
used to do
we used to do relationships we still
have this expectation this ideal of this
20th century model for relationships in
an age where we look at a dramatic spike
like that in how people meet online and
again you have to also you can't just
take that one data point and and just
like say this is it yeah there's all
other interrelated data points that go
along with that you're also looking at
men who are falling out of you know the
the lost boys generation the guys who
are not getting laid right now because
they it's i'm looking at the gss study
right now men are far more sexless today
than at any other time in in history any
other generation in history the whole
well it is it's in cell concept but it's
also statistically a reality yeah my
friend david's dealing with right it's
like 28 right
i just read this thing is 28 percent of
men below the age of 30 are sexless they
are they're still either virgins what's
that number again 28 of men below the
age of 30 you know up to 30 are sexless
what can those guys do is this some of
the big the triad make more money yeah
money muscles game yeah and and i mean
that's if you want a prescription that's
what i would that's where i would go to
however that data point set against this
stuff you're going to ask me why is poly
a big deal why is it now where we're not
getting married why is uh well of course
divorce rates are lower now as well
because nobody's getting married
um and so we're looking for alternatives
to that right now we're looking for uh
alternative ways of forming families and
i think we're kind of doing a piss-poor
job of it right now because we're still
thinking that we can get back to this uh
you know 20th century uh model for
relationships in an age where 28 of men
below 30 aren't aren't getting any and
we're looking at how are they how are
they finding each other okay also look
at how what are the what's the
demographics and what is the uh what are
the numbers of men versus women on those
dating apps to begin with it's mostly
men and uh
like an ocean of men and like a very few
select uh set of women who are getting
those responses you know what's unique
about you is that in some fashion you're
a traditionalist meaning you've been
married for 30 years you're married
25 years ride the cusp yes right so what
does that mean exactly i ride the fence
man i i can remember a pre-internet age
and i post internet agents so i'm gonna
and by the way once i'm the last of my
kind because once we're gone nobody's
gonna have that that preconception
anymore certainly not to the degree that
i don't know writing about i don't know
about that well i don't want that they
want that conventional they want that
conventional monogamy i think there's
always going to be we sometimes think
we're more important than we really are
and there's nothing wrong with being
that confident that's great but i think
people like you
are always going to be there to
challenge conventional thinking i hope
there's oh there's going to be it's no
question listen jewish proverb three
things every man should do is what write
a book plant a tree have a son right i
mean it's a it would it the whole
purpose behind it doesn't mean go have a
son today it's just saying like the fact
that when you do that
uh uh messages go to the next one i ask
this open relationship thing because of
the one show that we're doing but it's
also it's been coming up and hey
you think it's this you think it's that
what about this because sometimes you
got single guys that want to get married
who don't want to give up the life of
being single okay
you know how you talk about in your 20s
never fully commit to one i don't know
what word you use but you you 48 laws of
power by the way yeah of course robert
greene top well you talk about that as
well where
you know
keep your options open when you're young
single tell your doctor don't consider
monogamy until yeah so that's what you
say that's that's what you say okay
um you know so so you're kind of like
when you're single you know you don't
have the what's the rca uh uh
responsibility commitment accountability
right those three things that we fear
that we don't want we just i don't want
to be responsible for one i don't want
to be committed to one i don't want to
be counted but the reality of it is
you're going to be married for 25 years
if you don't follow the rca rule and
commit to that right
um
how does how does one who is single and
has been single for a while
and has been very good at being single
for a while
how does that person who is now
especially and this is going to sound
like i'm talking about you but i'm
talking about a lot of friends right now
that we have that are
late 30s early 40s
they don't need to get married they're
doing great they're making money
but they're getting to a point where
they're sitting there saying i wouldn't
mind having a kid right i wouldn't mind
having a family honestly i'm so sick of
it the number that used to matter when
you would brag to your friends you know
the number like oh i've been with this
many others
no one cares anymore like who cares
about what the number is anymore at this
point it mattered in 20s it doesn't
matter in your 40s
what what challenges is that 40 year old
male gonna face to go from being fully
free
for many many years to all of a sudden
decide to commit to one person and build
a family what challenge is that guy
going to face it's i i have
my friend john from modern life dating
is probably a pretty good example of
this as well is once you get to that
point once you get to like 36 37 years
old and let's just say you've been on
your game you have maximized your
potential uh as you know your value as a
guy
there will come a point where you have
um
let's just say solve the mystery of
women you've solved the mystery of money
you've solved the mystery of whatever it
is that sort of has been your obsession
for as long as it has been and now it
seems kind of like uh
like old old news to you and what's the
next challenge what's what's next what's
the next goal and i
i have said this as well is that i think
that again that men and women are innate
compliments we're better together than
we are apart and i think that at some
stage men are going to say you know what
i would rather have the quality than the
quantity
but those guys don't get to that stage
unless they kind of go through the idea
that they either had the cos the
quantity or that they could have had the
quantity
most men like i said when the average
age of marriage for men is
the ones that are getting married is
like 29 years old that also coincides
right at that epiphany phase that i was
just talking to you guys about so when
that guy's 29 years old and he's not
quite reached his peak potential when he
gets to 36 37 years old and he's already
committed to a woman who was like 20
years you know 28 years old back in the
day he might be thinking well damn i
didn't know i was going to be this hot i
didn't know i was going to have this
much money i didn't know i was going to
be at this status and that's why you get
things like the midlife crisis at that
point and so it's not so much a midlife
crisis as it is oh damn i now realize my
own potential
and uh now i'm having second thoughts or
now i'm like you know i'm i'm going to
go buy a sports car so i'll relive my my
youth
um that's really sort of where that
comes from but when those guys are
are not committed and they get to 230
that's one scenario the other scenario
is the one you just said is when they
get to be 36 37 years old maybe 38 years
old pushing 40 and they go you know what
i'm i'm done with this i really kind of
want to want to log out and i want to
you know have something that's a little
more permanent they'll ask me they'll
say rolo i don't want to get with one of
these girls i'm fresh and fit who's like
18 22 years old because they seem kind
of really you know flighty and and not
somebody you want to start something
with but also i don't want to get with a
woman who's sort of like used up and is
really kind of full of herself an alpha
female at 33 years old who has sort of
built herself into that archetype
how do i solve my problem i tell them
you say you know you have to look for
certain you have to be a good judge of
character you've got to be able to if
you're reading my books if you've if
you're red pill aware if you're a good
judge of character if you maximize your
potential i've always said that the the
sweet spot is kind of somewhere between
like say 25 and 27 years old and looking
for a woman who uh who understands like
what her sexual market value is versus
what her personal value is and those
women do exist
and i want to point that out it's not
like i think a lot of people think that
i think all women are the same no or all
men are the same no i'm not saying that
there are commonalities that are that
are characteristic of men and women we
have our sort of innate differences of
course but when you're talking to like
women in different cultures in different
religions in different countries
wherever though those cultures are going
to be vastly different than they are
here in the united states because maybe
they haven't sort of been corrupted with
like you know feminism or whatever to
that point so you're looking at women in
like muslim like muslim majority
countries you're looking at latin latin
countries those
those women are going to be of a
different kind of like understanding of
like going forward this is what i'm what
i'm going to be about so there's a lot
of variables that give you a culture so
so so at that very this is what i took
from wood and and i'm curious what your
follow-up's going to be there is i'll
turn it over to you right after this so
to me based on what you just said this
is what i took away from it culture and
uh uh tradition
is something you ought to value at that
age you ought to look for that is that
kind of what you're saying you should at
least have a good understanding of what
how that person with male or female came
to
their certainly their belief sets but
also uh what is it that has acculturated
them into the personalities that they
have so definitely you know there's
environmental influences there's natural
innate influences and then there's
cultural influences as well what do you
think about that you know
you know split your h plus seven
plus seven f plus seven yeah
well let me tell you something about
like age appropriateness it only works
in the female sense it doesn't work in
the male sense because we live in a
gynocentric social order that says well
you know uh was it uh
keanu reeves they when he was dating his
his uh i think she was like 46 and he's
like my age like 53 or 54 years old and
the woman he was dating at the time
looks like his mother looks like they
like she's got gray hair and everything
and women were just like yeah he's
dating somebody that's uh that's age
appropriate you look at leonardo
dicaprio none of his girlfriends have
been older than 25 years old and as soon
as they get to 26 he cycles them out and
gets another 23 years
of milk exactly and so that's and and
you can there are actually online sites
that like track his his girlfriend's
ages across the so who's doing it right
who is leo doing it right or is is uh is
keanu doing it right is keanu still with
the lady i don't i don't know but that
was yeah that's the that's the the gal
right there i believe hugh jackman is
like yeah hugh jackman hugh jackman is
my age he's 53 and his wife is 66 years
old what's uh jason jason momoa just
broke up with uh lisa bonay who is 54
and i believe he's 41 or 42. lisa monet
had it going on for and she was with
lenny kravitz
macron
pm of france is the president prime
minister or whatever yeah his wife is
like 20 years older than him but we only
have we only have we only have a problem
with age appropriateness when it is a
man that is dating uh you know
too young so what's too young half plus
seven is it ten years yeah if you look
at the difference between say um
like uh lisa bonnet and and jason momoa
what's that about a 10-year difference
yeah well 13 years so if you've got a
guy who's 33 and he's dating a
20-year-old girl technically it's
illegal you could go ahead and do that
but we go oh my gosh he's robbing the
cradle right but if it's the other way
around oh she's a cougar
i don't think about it i just think is
it going to work
you know you you may you may be like oh
that's cool you know more and ashton
yes
yeah well
he brought up a really good story
because almost like the
case example he was giving is
essentially me so the
you know ultimately a lot of the
questions that you ask are who do you
want to be yeah right so who do you want
to be who i want to be now at age 41
is a lot different than who i wanted to
be at age 31. so it really
like i'll give you a story
congratulations you've matured all right
well yeah but that comes with
finding your purpose
making money having some heartbreak
issues whatever you know good
relationships bad relations it happens
through life but ultimately you have to
be like okay
do i want to be single at 51 hell no who
do i want to be like thank god i have a
got a lot of good people in my ear like
pat that shows me all right cool you can
be successful you can have money you can
still have fun you can be a family man
you can do it all you can have it all if
that's what you want so
i tell the story on uh podcast that i do
that i believe that you're going to be
on thursday so i met a girl that i
haven't seen in years
uh out i saw her i saw her out or i
didn't know that i knew her but i was
like oh she's really attractive tall
whatever we get to talking i'm like oh
yeah i remember yeah what kyle i'm like
how old are you i'm 40. you're 40. you
look incredible she's like yeah we
should get together sometime you know
here's my number call me i never called
her
40.
i'm thinking i don't think that's going
to work out so much because i'm thinking
i want to get married i want to have
kids
that's just not going to be in my yeah
and then you're speaking of polyamory so
this past weekend
um i'm out it's my birthday south beach
having a fun time
i i see a girl that i hadn't seen in a
little while she goes what's up how are
you you have a girlfriend no jokingly i
go do you have a girlfriend ha ha she
goes yeah actually i do
like oh okay this is gonna get fun
um she's like you should come out with
us whatever whatever so
um
i'm out with her and her girlfriend but
we're kind of got a thing going on and
we have a thing it's my birthday she
gives me a kiss or whatever i'm like
what's why is your friend like having a
bad attitude she's like i don't know she
kind of feels like a third wheel she's
like i think it would be a lot better
and make things less awkward if you kiss
her i'm like okay
so boom make out with a friend now so
now i'm making out two girls it's kind
of insane
and i'm telling my boys this like the
next day
and they're like so almost like you know
adrian whatever was like bro
are you kidding me you gotta take the
dude two girls oh my god you had like
like there's that friend right it's like
a steel panther exactly exactly and then
there's the other friend that's like you
know almost like the angel the devil
it's like listen bro like you know you
really want to mess with these kind of
like
ratchet not just she was ratchet but
these more excuse like scandalous type
girls is that really what you're looking
for so there's part of me that's like
this is for most men i would assume but
by the way the fact that you're being
that transparent about it yeah yeah
most men wanna like are thinking here's
the difference yeah here's it here's the
difference though here's the difference
though here's the difference
uh uh uh adam is in shape
he's made money attractive charming
charismatic
you would be qualified as a natural
so for you you're six one
athlete you are extremely likable people
like you you don't have enemies you're
chill you're cool to be around right you
have that side
i think and correct me if i'm wrong it's
harder for you to want to consider
to want to build that
you know that life because for me when i
was when i was i got out of one
relationship
me and this girl were together she's a
libra i'm a libra
you know we when we were friends tight
great
but she was so dominant personality
super competitive
and you know honestly like we were part
of a week away from world war iii
there's no way that's going to be
negative
so you know afterwards i'm kind of like
i was convinced i sat down with the uh
leo's wife patty and i said patty you
know what listen i just come to a
conclusion i actually enjoy my own
company
i actually enjoy my own company so what
are you talking about i'm telling you
i'm the guy
that on sundays
i will wake up in the morning i'll go to
santa monica i'll do the stairs i'll go
to the gym i'll go to the beach that i
go to i'll go to the same seat i sit at
that pf chang's in the corner the same
waiter
gives me four arnold palmer's i eat the
same exact freaking thing i call the
same person that i go spend some time
with then i go to this place and then i
come and i go to the office and i work
all night and i start monday morning i'm
totally fine i said i'm gonna have six
and a half days to work against my
competitors everybody else is going to
work five days a week why would i want
to get married right right right i'm
going through this process and i have
options i'm it's not like um logistics
and pragmatism exactly and it's like you
know what if you have a wife if you have
kids do you really want to
have that and all this other stuff now
there's a different side of me as well
that
you know god's played a very important
role in my life and i'm talking
incredible or i would not be where i'm
at right now without the man upstairs
believe me so so the fight i had on both
sides is like i i want to
you know i want to be a good example i
want to lead but i got this side that's
a
yeah like a tasmanian devil don't
control me leave me alone all this other
stuff right what it did to me is the
following here's what it did
i got to a point where i realized i want
to have a family i want to have kids
and i don't know what else am i going to
get out of my system like it was like
what else do i need to do to get the
check mark like you know you get that
checklist with 42 things to do before
you get married i'm not like 44 so i'm
like okay so what what else you got to
experience to say wow this is so cool
what happened to you right so there
comes that moment where you sit there
and you say i ain't going to be this age
forever one day i'm going to be 50 60
70. do i want to be the 62 year old
dating a 26 year old every other day or
do i want to be the 60 year old having
been with the same person for 16 17
years and looking forward because i'm
teaching my son or my daughter and i'm
living you know through them and i'm
teaching them certain values and
principles that maybe i learned from
mistakes i made stuff i learned from my
mom my dad whoever it is and i'm passing
down to somebody i think that's the
battle for a guy who's a performer who's
crushing it sitting there saying but for
my my thoughts correct me if you're if
you disagree with this i think for that
to happen
um i was kind of seeing what angle you
were going to take what direction you
were going to go i think for that to
happen
certain
uh
certain rituals has to change oh yeah
okay i i just think certain things have
have to change like for example you know
everybody that's going after joe rogan
it's a cool thing to do right to go
after joe rogan yeah that's right let me
tell you i can't believe he said that
you know even joe rogan is going after
him by the way you know shout out to
dave portenoid i don't know if you did
did you watch that episode or no did you
ever see that okay so you don't need to
pull it up because it's on a different
podcast but dave portnoy is doing a
podcast with these three guys what's
their names
which by the way they're great for the
democrats on what they're doing they're
super true believers they support them
they go after everybody and they're who
you want on your side okay
they're the patrick beverly is they're
that guy that you want on your team
right son of a the son of yeah
you want that like you know you got
three people the dreamer the businessman
and the son of a you need that
right
so what happens when you point finger
non-stop to everybody joe's a racist
joe's this jose joseph he said this he
said that so you know uh howard story
let me tell you we gotta no problem okay
just yesterday a video came out by
howard stern making fun of whoopi
goldberg and using did you see how
uncomfortable it's so uncomfortable to
even watch this right he said so many
things about this guy okay about the
blacks the words he used
and then this guy that dave portnoy's
inter interview with them the three guys
on his podcast look well uh
dave let me ask you this do you think
it's okay for joe to use the n-word
so dave says uh
uh listen i've already answered that
question i'm not gonna answer the
question again but here's what i will do
so what if i told you i have a text from
one of you three here that use the n
word
and there's three brothers
and they're quiet you have to see this
okay
what if what if you know uh i'm able to
find the text that you guys well you
prove it
wanna the two brothers say prove it one
brother doesn't say prove it so you know
the one brother that says prove it it's
like shut up
what are you saying and he says
were one of you guys engaged a girl
named lexi and you should see this one
guy's face he's like
he's so classic just i have a text shake
i have a text
that you use the n word in the text
and it was like oh we can't now
cancel our brother you know oh man so it
kind of catches up to you right it flips
on you turns on you then the rock well
let me tell you you know now that i
learned i've gotten educated and rock is
on and then it's like hey video comes
back about what he said about the you
know making fun of chinese and so where
is this thing right i think certain
things you have to cut away from you
have to cut away from the idea of that
people walk on water and perfection and
that's just not going to exist right so
let me bring you back i went all over
the place and added four other current
events which checklist for you tyler but
here's where i'm going with this okay
here's where i'm going with this
um
the older i get the older you get it's
gonna be harder to find somebody that's
gonna meet all the criterias you're
looking for because no one walks on
water that's number one so you're always
going to be like
no no yeah but no no yes parents family
education church
height toes hair face nose skin so
church
no no no so ain't nobody gonna fit that
there's gotta be somebody because you
don't walk on water i definitely
don't walk on water so hey what are we
gonna do with this right
and if you're gonna do that certain
things have to dramatically change like
if we're going to go into this era of
media where we're going to be holding
everybody accountable for stuff that
they say you have to know
we have to cut away from
everybody has to walk on water nobody
does the moment you open your mouth you
risk you risk criticizing and offending
somebody that's why i think i think i
think the older you get you have to
really make a decision there and say you
know what i gotta remember when i said
yeah i want to build a family i
stopped
communicating with certain people that i
know i wasn't going to i went
immediately and made a list i read this
book and i went and started dating these
four girls not promiscuous we were not
this was not a sexual relationship i'm
dating four girls every one of them i
did the exercise with and the next thing
you know you know it got to
somebody and i said i think this one's
going to work out and jennifer and i
went through the 101 questions to ask
before you get engaged
18 months later we're married now we got
four kids we're married for 12 and a
half years do i think that's going to
last for the rest of my life i have no
clue from the day i got married i said
we're going to take this one year at a
time and we've done it 12 times so far
right because you never know what's
going to change with your life or her
life or anything anything else that
could happen all i'm saying is if if
somebody at that age wants to make that
dramatic change
certain lifestyle things got to change
that's just i may be wrong but that's
what i'm thinking when when people ask
me uh they
people who hate on me or criticize me
they usually come at it from two
different angles one of them is rolo
can't be red pill he's married so
therefore i have no experience or i'm
not out in the game and i'm not out
there hustling and i'm not out there in
the clubs and you know picking up you
know girls and and getting my notch
count up
and then there's the guys who will say
well rollo can't be married he's red
pill and that's usually the the
traditional conservative guys who are uh
who want to say well you know uh you you
you don't agree with marriage like i've
i've come out very vocally against
marriage on several occasions and this
is from a guy who has been in you know
for the last 25 years what i think most
men would consider a pretty ideal
marriage
and
when people get upset with me about
saying that you know marriage is an
unconscionable contract or men have more
maneuverability they have more
flexibility than more opportunities
outside of marriage today than they do
inside marriage people just think i am
anti-marriage i am not i would very much
still 100 maybe it's the old school in
me but i still 100 believe in the
institution of marriage and i would love
for nothing better than for for you and
anyone else watching this if you're a
guy i would love for you to have what i
have
had for you know the last 25 years and
we're like 26 and a half but um
i would love for you to be able to have
that but i can't endorse that i can't
advocate for that right now because the
way we do marriage today is completely
all downside risk for most guys at this
point so when you're talking to me about
like well you know i just i made out
with two chicks and i got i'm on top of
my game i'm hitting my stride i'm you
know what you're in your 40s but let's
just say you know 36 38 somewhere around
there um i am at the peak of my sexual
selectivity right now and i'm going to
finally enjoy it because i had to eat
from the time i was 20 or 18 in
high school all the way up to where i'm
at right now because i had to come up i
had to i had to pay my dues and get to
the point where i'm at right now and
you're telling me i've got to settle on
one woman in a state of westernized
marriage right now where i'm first of
all i can lose half of my stuff and then
second of all it's like why would i want
to get into that situation when i'm
finally hitting my stride and a lot of
guys because it takes longer for them to
mature into their peak potential
there they don't see any point and say
you know the guys who are the high the
high value the highest value men out
there who have the money who have the
game who have the muscles who have all
that all of those checkpoints off that
women want to get with they the the
women that women are complaining the men
that women are complaining about that
they can't find a right the right guy
you're the guy
not that not the
the army of beta males that they like
rejected all throughout their 20s
they're complaining about a guy who
won't settle down and now you're
infantile you have a fragile ego you're
threatened by strong women because you
won't commit to her when you're finally
at the position in your life at 36 where
she was when she was 23 years old and
nobody gave her any kind of worry for it
back then so what you're what you're up
against and what you're talking about as
well is when you get to that point you
have to decide what opportunities and
what are the compromises and what are
the sacrifices i'm willing to make as a
man in my in my
peak potential years what what
compromises am i willing to make for a
woman for me to want to say you know
what i'm going to give up all that
opportunity for you and is that woman
going to appreciate that is she going to
be oh well thank you for for doing that
or is she going to be entitled to the
fact that she believes that she belongs
with a guy who's a high value guy as it
is and that's the paradox that's going
you want to know why the marriage rates
are low you want to know why uh was
morgan stanley forecasted that by 2030
women in prime working demographic age
like was it 25 to 45 of of that that
cohort
42 i believe are going to be single and
childless during that time at by 2030
and that's
how does that change a society how does
that change the united states how does
that change a western you know our
western way of life when we have this
you know high high demographic of women
yeah with population of women who are
not marrying not having kids right now
there's just a another uh article i
think it was in uh in the uk how women
after 30 of women after the age of 30
are don't have kids and they don't have
any prospects to have kids that does a
number on women do they want kids though
but yeah they do with you
they want kids with the god well the guy
who's the high value they're outside
they want to with the guy who's um so
they're not gonna settle who's of your
who's of your characteristics there's a
i don't know i should have called it up
but there is actually a calculator on
it's called like the female delusion
calculator and you type in like women
say okay i want a guy with six foot tall
i want a guy to make you know 100 000 a
year he's got to be available there's
all these little you know criteria and
it will show you
what the um what the percentage chance
is or what the what percentage of the
population that's it right there what
percentage of the population
you should type that in like
go down there and it do a quick it's
very easy go do a quick experiment
should do one for do one for him do do
for his age what's your age again 41 41
so let's let's get into 41.
you are white
so we can put that in uh how tall are
you six foot six foot oh man uh and
minimum income i presume you said you
you'd make six figures no one more
correct okay so
it maxes out it maxes out a hundred
thousand okay now find
the probability of finding a guy like
you is point one three percent
what you can see adam's ego just one
another
four before and i always say your ego is
not your amigos
you just
if you go and you look at how they they
rate this these are all statistics that
are available by census bureau data
yes
so statistically speaking like if women
wanted a guy that is just like you you
you are a representative of point
thirteen percent of the popular the us
population came over this is all we're
gonna hear all day my confidence just
went through the room
all day all month
now you know why polly is popular now do
you know why guys are holding like when
you get to you know you're hitting your
shirt what would you tell a guy
like if you're saying you are married
you're happily married you want to have
like i'm telling you i've lived in south
beach my whole life
you do not want to be the 60 year old
guy in the club i know that i've seen
like i remember saying i'm going to do
well i'm going to make that anyways i
don't like there's no chance that i'm
going to be 50 still out there in the
club a club space in miami it's not
happening like but what would you tell a
guy because there's a lot of sick
there's entrepreneurs here people
believe in capitalism people with
self-improvement a lot of people watch
this channel because they want to do
better and they're thinking big that's
kind of what our brand is what would you
tell the person whether they're 32 35 40
45 whatever and they haven't settled
down yet what advice do you have for
them i'll tell you i had this
conversation with my friend rich cooper
and he asked me on his show one time how
did you vet for mrs tomas and my answer
was i didn't vet her i vetted myself
first
i asked myself the first question i said
is like when i was considering actually
having being married to anyone at that
point um was is this a person that i can
be faithful to is this a person that i
can because i know what happens when
that when a couple splits up i know what
happens to a family to multiple families
to the children to everything else that
goes along in there there's by one of
the i think the
unspoken importances of the red pill is
that we don't it well it will at least
allow you to see uh like the the ripple
effect the cascade effect so what are
your actions doing right now that are
going to affect other people and so when
i was vetting my wife i don't say being
vetting um i had to vet myself i said
can i be faithful to this woman because
i know me i've seen me do it right i've
been the cheated on and i have been the
cheater myself in my in my past right
and so i don't want to
open that can of worms if if i don't if
i can't be 100 and the answer was yes i
could and that was the first question i
asked myself and really i think in in
your instance right now what
opportunities are you willing to
sacrifice what what are you willing to
compromise right now are you willing to
compromise making out with two girls on
the beach right are you willing to
compromise the opportunities it's like
opportunity there you go right here you
go pros and cons pros and cons
what what are you willing to sacrifice
and what are what's a deal breaker and
what's not a deal breaker and then what
you have to do is once you have decided
what that is you have to set that
against the girls that you think that
are are good candidates for a long-term
relationship that's very difficult for
guys to do right now well what is what
is the biggest fear in somebody in his
situation is it just i have to be with
one for the rest of my life i can't
party anymore i have to give up some of
my freedom what else is it why would
somebody cost opportunity costs for sure
like what are the what are the
opportunities that even myself take
myself as an example too i've been
married for 25 years what opportunities
have i missed out and not just sexual
opportunities i mean like business
opportunities or job opportunities or
relocation opportunities or family or
whatever else that maybe i wanted to do
that i could not do as a result of
having a relationship with you know
being in a marriage
having a kid having my dogs whatever
else all of that stuff all the
responsibilities that we say is you know
men need to take on responsibilities
well that response those
responsibilities come at a cost and that
cost is generally
scaled out at whatever those
opportunities were that you could have
invested yourself into had you not been
uh had you not been single or had you
been not been married at that time you
would not be who you are right now at 42
with the money you have and being
certainly you know 0.13 of the
population had you made a different
decision when you were 28 you know 30
years old when i got married right i'm a
different person as a result of that you
know it's life choices it's lifestyle
decisions but most guys don't make those
decisions based on educated you know
educated assumptions so right now you
have a life of learned experiences that
you can kind of reflect back on you
probably better judge a character minute
what's the joke you know men don't
become men until they're 30 years old
and so the reason why i say don't
consider monogamy until you're 30 or you
certainly don't even consider marriage
if you're going to consider marriage
until you get to be about 34 35 years
old
is because you're at that point where
you're finally hitting your stride and
you're a better judge of character and
you're better able to make that
that estimate that evaluation between
what are the opportunities i'm going to
miss and what are the um what are the
benefits of me you know settling down
with a with a woman for a very long time
and you know making things work out
would you call that earlier frame that's
definitely your frame you have to have
the frame by the way is the world into
which you enter or she enters
and you right now have a world that a
lot of certainly a lot of women would
like to enter into
and so you have to come in well and then
you also have to make sure that you have
to keep that in mind when you're making
the decision is this someone that i can
be faithful to
when you said that was the first
question that you asked yourself when
you were going to settle down why was
that the first question was that well
because i like i said i know me you know
i it definitely it is because uh it is i
think a lot of people under
appreciate the effect of genuine desire
and genuine desire is like unmitigated
like and you know
in a sexual sense it's unmitigated you
know lust like there's a there's a
qualifiable difference between a man
work that a woman says i want to have
kids it's time for me to have kids my
biological clock is ticking and that
woman says i want to have his babies i
want to have that guy's family i want
him i want to i basically want to you
know reproduce with that guy there's a
big difference between those two
statements
has it been hard for you
being that what you talk about what you
stand for to be faithful
um no because i i i was able to answer
that question back then can i be
faithful to her and she was she was
everything i was looking for it still is
everything i'm looking for
he's about to get emotional
yeah that's
when you're 28 that's yeah okay i'll be
faithful well i've had like we've seen
we've seen the video of urban meyer
who's married and whatever and now he's
getting a lap dance at the bar from a
girl in jacksonville and i'm not sure
that he i don't know what he did that
was necessarily too wrong but he wasn't
necessarily faithful but um
well there's a bit what you say when
you're 28 what happens when you're 41 in
a club yeah but jordan peterson let me
ask a question what did you think when
jordan peterson said you know divorce
should be 100 out of the question
oh that's right how do you process that
how do you process that yeah jordan
peterson said that no matter how bad
your marriage is you should stay married
for the sake of the kids essentially
advocating for the what nuclear family
that is that 100 so even as miserable as
you are you're fighting you're not
having sex with your f you know you're
not meant to be
at what point do you say you know we
tried enough enough what is your and at
what age of the kids okay
do you think no matter what you should
stay married i think that if you again
one of the reasons why i vetted myself
before i vetted my wife was because of
exactly that can i be faithful this
person because if i can't then i should
not be reproducing and starting a family
and building this huge
you know
world or my frame around all of this if
that one little point at that one
fundamental point can't be can't be
maintained so yeah sex is the glue that
holds relationships together sex is the
glue that holds marriages together and
if that falls apart i mean you go look
at the statistics for uh sexless
marriages in the united states right now
it's like something like at least 20
percent and a sexist marriage by the way
is like
10 times a year right like one uh like
once a month or you know and then skip
two months i think that's what uh well
you're saying you should stay married
even if you're in a sex
i think that once you're already in that
um i think it's very important to uh as
far as raising the children if you want
to build strong families now a lot of
people will disagree with me on that
because they'll say well you know i'm
not getting what i need out of the
relationship and it's usually the woman
that is saying that it's not so much the
man that men will will put up and
tolerate way more than women will when
it comes to like a bad marriage because
they have more to lose women are more
incentivized financially incentivized to
uh to file for divorce this is one of
the reasons why 70 of divorces are
initiated by women then you get like
social narratives like um like what we
call divorce porn which is like eat pray
love right or stella got her groove back
or uh just divorce him girl he's not the
one for you he was never your soul mate
you need to go run off to jamaica and
have a good time and find your soul mate
there after you divorce pretty good
movie but that's about it it's divorce
porn it's a fantasy for women who are
like who get to the point where they
they settled on a guy who was not the
the the one was not their soulmate you
know the one that got away was the guy
who in their in their in their college
days
and they get you want to know why they
call it the seven year itch it's because
it's usually right around seven years
that women have that you know they
decide is he the best that i can do and
more and more certainly since the 70s
when the answer to that is no and to the
point where we can go build you know
very you know profitable franchises and
romance novels and narratives right go
look at uh anything like netflix has is
chock full of those narratives fifty
shades of french
the biggest thing fifty shades of grey
by the way remember 50 shades of grey
was
self-published it was not like put 200
errors in the book yes and it sold 65
million copies in the first like like
year or that what do you mean a few
errors oh it was self-published the guy
had like who's who's lose lose loose
loose like spelling errors basically fan
fiction but it was just rewritten by uh
el or eel something or i can't remember
50 some year old was
late 40 i don't know how old she was but
she was hit on a very popular narrative
because it's a fantasy it's the fantasy
of i'm gonna and it's a it's a fantasy
with a lot of commonalities in it as
well but you have to look at the
popularity of that i mean i remember in
we talked about church i remember church
women going have you read fifty shades
of grey i can't wait till the movie
comes out and it was all good in the
hood to be to be reading this the movie
sucked but the soundtrack and you know
and you know what you know what pastors
of the arabic you know you know
religious guys of the era did they say
oh it's a failure of men
it's a failure of men that we that we've
allowed this to happen with women or we
can't live up we can't measure up to
that and so we'll we're ready to
self-flagellate and blame ourselves for
those for for you know the
impulses let's just say so so let me let
me uh let me ask a question just from
you i'm going to ask a question do you
think
the more
intel you get
the more it's kind of like well sure you
got to do this and you got to do oh no
this guy said this on that guy we're
going to you know this guy said oh but
this guy said that but that guy said
this but this guy said this were you
kind of like data overload yeah data
overload to the point where you can't
make a decision do you think that kind
of hurts hurts a little bit
i can see for the type of person that
gets in your head and second guesses
everything why that would hurt but i'm
the type of person that's going to
remember the two or three most powerful
things that someone says they're two or
three you know and i say all right cool
this is what i'm taking from this
because not everyone's going to remember
every single part of this video that's
not what i'm asking what i'm asking what
i'm asking is do you i think you
understand what i'm asking what i'm
asking is it's kind of like
um you
you almost read like if i knew
at 21 years old how hard it was going to
be to be an entrepreneur and somebody
would have told me i i don't know if i
would have gone if somebody would have
told me flat out here's i would have
been like if they would have sat there
and said let me tell you here's what's
going to be here's what's going to be
here's what's going to be here's what's
like it was more listen
if you do this here's what your life
could look like this is the dream
this is the dream life that could look
like but guess what the chances of you
living this dream life is one percent
if that scares the crap out of you
don't do it
if you're all in and your dreams matter
go for it go light it up right but the
choice and the onus is on who on you and
i to do that marriage
i had to get to this place to get
married just so you know i'll tell you
where i had to get to
i had to get to
divorce was a challenge because my
parents got a divorce and as a kid
i always like as a kid i think about
when my dad would walk up the stairs in
iran and he would come to the fourth
floor the happiest day of my moment of
my day was a five minutes when i would
see his head go like this with the steps
because our door was glass and i would
see his head go up like this i would run
up to him five minutes wrestle i'd go to
sleep i was good i was at peace right
when they got a divorce that head coming
up the steps disappeared in my life
that's it believe it or not that's all i
remember i loved that moment with my mom
and dad they got a divorce right and i
got the words twice in 20 years by the
way my parents so i sat there and i said
well and both of them neither one of
them were supportive of the other it's
kind of like well you know marriage is
not this and let me tell you a woman
manager
all this stuff right i should have done
this and i should have done this i
should have done this and i would this
was this girl and there was this guy and
what if this everybody you don't
understand when i was younger we always
say when i was younger i was so
attracted i was so disciplined great
fantastic so there's some regrets we're
all gonna have no matter what the
decision we make right okay
and then later on it got to a point
where i said all right so let's just
face it there's a possibility that could
get a divorce but guess what parents did
the right thing getting a divorce
my parents did the right thing getting a
divorce and you turned that okay and so
did your sister turn out okay
so this whole thing that it's gonna ruin
the kids it does absolutely it does
emotionally fear all this anxiety one
million percent by yourself that's not
there i can't come i can't talk to
somebody the phases you go through as a
kid being bullied certainly you don't
have you can't talk to your mom the same
way we talk to your dad the same we
can't talk to your dad the way you talk
to your mom about certain things right
so when that disappears it's gonna mess
with you a little bit but there's books
there's therapy there's church there's a
lot of different ways you can rehash
that and heal yourself just like you
have just like i've had just like many
of us have had to do right
then it got to a point where i said
the one simple question all right so
what's the worst case scenario what's
going to happen
okay let's look at both ways what's the
worst thing that's going to happen that
if you choose not to get married
you're 63 years old sitting there saying
when your friend's son is graduating
from college and you're there and all
you're thinking about is while you're
clapping for this kid you're thinking
when your friend had that kid and he met
the girl and you were there and my kids
graduated in college and i was a doctor
and the emotional moment the father
experienced with the son or the daughter
you're saying i want that
you know or you're by yourself and you
have all these girlfriends that you're
with but there's nobody that you have
depth of 30 years to share memories with
you like i have it kind of cool to have
that best friendships when i see you and
keith together it's freaking awesome
well when we went to dinner the other
day who spoke to us at the dinner the
other day i didn't speak at all
for three hours i just listened to the
stories it was freaking amazing seeing
the connection that you guys have that's
like a marriage except it's a friendship
but it's a marriage right some friends
didn't make it
some are now with us some are not here
with us and that's just the reality of
it
but the worst case scenario on the other
side
is if it doesn't work out
it's a divorce
if it's a divorce you can take
everything away from me not true there's
great legal teams out there that you can
set things up upfront to manage
expectations up front there's something
called nuptial agreement so the
financial side okay that's out the
window arrangements what about this now
you're going to be fine with that as
well because everything can be on paper
up front okay
those are the things that takes it out
because
i'm i'm from the school of thought of
where i'm at today's i don't think
you know a lot of people are like listen
i'm at that age i got to get married
because everyone's getting married
that's not true who cares if everyone's
getting married everyone's having kids
who cares if that's not a reason to get
married that's not a reason to get
married at all for either so absolutely
i i've met people that are not married
and they're very happy
they're very very happy and content but
i've met more people that are not
married and they're miserable okay it's
just everything becomes a guy put a
comment here and i said fantastic
comment that you just put up
it's
odds everything is about odds
everything in life is about odds there
is a no hundred percent better now
investment that just doesn't exist well
i think a lot of people believe that
they're going to just stumble into a
perfect turnkey relationship you have to
remember that right like a relationship
a good marriage like or even a good
friendship is something that you develop
over time it's like building a project
together it is not just about like oh
look i found this you know my brand new
car and i'm gonna go drive my brand new
car it's it's something that you have to
uh
build upon it's it's like it's almost
like an art project you know it's like
you you collaborate i play in a band
right we make music together all four of
us make music together and it's not just
about one particular guy it's about all
of us you know coming together
collaborating down putting something
together you can look at it in those
perspe and that in that perspective then
yeah it becomes it becomes something
that's i think um
i know i know dr peterson would i would
say it's like more meaningful but i
would say it's certainly more
substantial it's more impactful um and
it produces something uh greater than
the like the sum of the parts so uh i i
definitely believe that uh the other the
one of the reasons why i was saying that
you know i think that um
staying together for the for the sake of
the kids a lot of guys will will end up
doing that you also remember that
divorce was at 50 of of marriages and in
divorce as it is right now and um again
um
then we have to look at how
what's the societal impact of divorce
what's the societal impact of single
mothers what is the societal impact of
women who electively have kids uh was it
42 percent of children are born out of
wedlock in the united states today
40 42
of children born in the united states
are born out of wedlock today
so that's terrible yes either electively
or they were together and then they
split up afterwards um and that's just a
that's a across the the non-demographics
it's just like across across the board
so what does that do to a society what
does or should we stay together for the
kids the other thing comes down to a and
this is a little i think a little more
uh ephemeral of a thought here is like
what is your
what is more important to you your
commitment or your commitment to the
ideal of commitment meaning like i keep
my commitments that's my commitment to
an ideal so it doesn't matter how bad
this situation gets i stuck it out
because i when i commit i commit to
something or is your commitment to
yourself saying this isn't working for
me i'm the i'm my own mental point of
origin i'm i'm you know the the primary
in this and this commitment was a bad
deal and i
now i need to get out of it because i
can't live like this anymore is your
commitment
more
your is it more important to be
committed to something or is it more
important to be committed to yourself
and that's where guys get when they get
into that situation when they thought it
was a great deal when they got married
and they find out that it's a raw deal
afterwards and then they also have to
take into account the opportunities and
the things that they could have
participated in had they not make that
commitment in the first place that's why
i said when you're talking about well
how should i vet my wife
understand what the opportunity costs
are on there most guys never they have
even an occasion to even think about
that they can't believe that they're
having sex with a girl in the first
place like oh well she must be the one
right and they're willing to go forward
from that from that perspective and
never get to the point where they're
actually thinking about standards or
vetting or anything else that goes along
with that because either they're you
know too you know too low value or
they're too high value and they're not
they don't on their way to their high
value-ness to to being you know an
entrepreneur making their first million
or whatever they're not thinking about
those questions and so they get into a
similar state of like trouble as a
result of that so when i say you know uh
you know i think that the divorce you
know women will say this all the time
divorce is off the table you think you
just said it a second ago there's this
idea that divorce should never be a
consideration but i'll say in
certainly in the 21st century divorce is
always on the table it is always
something that is available to women it
is always something that's going to say
is he not the one is he not the one is
he the best i can do and if that answer
is no there's always that option for her
for men it's it's cheaper to keep her
most of the time it's like
cheaper to keep her because they because
they don't want to go through all of the
rigor morale involved with you know
separating getting out of that so
those are things that i think every guy
when they're saying oh i think i want to
get married i want to have kids i want
to go forward those are questions that
you have to ask yourself and ask them
from an educated perspective so listen
for the listener that's that's listening
to this here's one thing i do want to
say before we wrap up
is many times
i see guys and gals who hear a message
and they emote immediately make an
emotional decision so meaning they call
their husband and say you know what
we're done call their wife or something
here's a call let's get married listen
guys this is just a conversation that we
could have gone five more hours this
isn't a conversation for you to all of a
sudden make a life-changing decision to
go get divorced get married or get
somebody knocked up not at all this is
some extreme ton of processing going on
that we spoke openly
and everybody gave different scenarios
you got a guy here that's been married
for 25 years in july whose daughter
turned 23
and he's given his perspective i'm
married for 12 years with four kids and
i'm a different story and then you got a
guy that's a single
uh a .13 percent one in a thousand type
of guy who's 40 39 or 40 years old and
he's single and he's thinking about
whether he should get married or not
everybody has a different life everybody
have a different situation they're
dealing with uh no two stories are the
same
you just gotta make sure when you're
making a bigger decisions in life you
don't jump to conclusion emotionally
just kind of take your time a little bit
more before you get too crazy
be rational
reason before emotion reason is really
before field yeah no question about it
seems to be a common theme but this is
just but this is this is a this is a
very aligned uh
uh what do you call a language with me
you know
i was talking to a guy the other day
says you know how are things good
i said um tell me about your family how
many kids you guys got we got one kid
are you guys trying four or two i've
been trying for five years
and you could tell he felt the pain
right that's an emotional thing right
there and i said listen bro there's
certain things i have no control of i
rely on a man upstairs
i try to do whatever i can to lead what
i can't control the stuff i cannot
control i'm not gonna do it i can't read
her mind i can't read future i can't do
any of that stuff the more you try to do
everything right you're going to break
so some things got to be left to
the man ups there's some things you got
to do and the rest see how things turn
out would you say that god is the third
person in your marriage
in ours absolutely
i'm i told the story like 12 podcasts
ago i'm dating a girl her and i love
each other we enjoy each other's company
i get to a point that i want to get
married i said listen i don't know if i
know what it is to be married
i think we need to go find a church
i'm an atheist at the time i'm telling
you right i'm an atheist at the time i
don't believe in god my life has never
given me a single example to believe in
god it's given me a thousand examples to
not believe that there's a god so i
don't want to go you know through this
mess
and i told her i said i want us to go to
church he says what are you talking
about i'm not going to church are you
becoming religious i said i'm the last
guy who you would call religious but if
we want to get married you want to i do
want to get married if you want to get
married i want to get married i think we
got to figure out a way to follow a
manual let's pick a manual so are we
going to pick the scientology manual are
we going to pick the christianity menu
are we going to pick the judaism are we
going to pick the lds
right let's pick a manual and go find
the best manual that we've grown we went
to church one time and i came out i said
listen why don't we try to go one month
without sex
so what are you talking about let's go
one month without sex
and it was the most awkward month and
the reason why i said let's go one month
without sex is just to see what do we
talk about outside of sex
what commonalities do we talk about
outside of sex i got to tell you it was
confusing for both of us guess what
happened a month later
relationship ended you know what's crazy
she's happily married
got a couple kids i'm happily married i
got four kids but i needed the man
upstairs because i by myself
you know sometimes you need that person
to be in your life you know when we sit
there we pray
with our kids in certain situations that
we have no concern daddy what do i do i
said buddy your daddy doesn't have all
the answers there's certain things that
we've got to pray about and those things
your mommy and daddy cannot help you out
with so anyways i don't want to make
this a spiritual so let's just end with
all holding hands yeah yeah heavenly
father yeah so anyways folks
this week last week we did four podcasts
and uh uh this week we're only doing one
podcast i think next week we're back to
two or three podcasts again actually i'm
traveling again next week but we have
john perkins on tuesday oh john perkins
economic man
you know who he is john perkins yeah
he's the one that goes to countries
negotiates with the prime ministers and
says if you don't do it
we're either going to take you out or
we're going to ruin your economy pretty
re and he did that for a living for like
a long time yeah it's cool we have some
surprise guess that's coming up by the
way that we can't release yet we got
some guys we got some surprises but we
got jason miller from getter on thursday
oh that's good next thursday okay very
cool okay uh gang and roller will be
here back with us on thursday on the
size cast with some ladies absolutely
here we go we're gonna put the link
below the rational mail 5 000 reviews on
amazon go order the book let's put the
link both on the chat box as well as the
con uh description and uh having said
that rolo thanks for coming up this was
great appreciate you appreciate it take
care guys have a great week bye bye bye
you